безусловно ai представляет угрозу чати
Это что было дальше меня просто люди не
знают в этом я этим занимаюсь но мы
сейчас видим как он за секунды создаёт
шедевры иллюстрации безумные он создаёт
сценарии невероятные Ну то есть с точки
зрения что он творец Я думаю вопросов
Мне кажется Ну вот прямо не остаётся
Google сразу же на прок это реально
альтернатива Гуглу Всё мы об люди
посмотрят этот выпуск и будут жить с
этим те
че
[музыка]
страшно друзья Сегодня мы начинаем
очередной выпуск нашего весеннего гемба
подкаста мы стараемся каждый месяц
снимать гемба подкаст как получается но
это ещё зависит от того какую тему
интересную тему мы находим и о чём есть
смысл и повод поговорить сегодняшняя
тема представлять я не буду гем подкаст
мы уже долго ведём Наверное поэтому вы
все знаете что это такое Что такое
и какой у нас формат напомню мы не
собираем экспертов поэтому не ждите от
нас какой-то глубины проработки вопроса
это просто неформальная посиделка
бизнесменов которые сидят на кухне и в
неформальной форме в лёгкой форме и в
простой форме обсуждает сложные вещи
которые беспокоят общественность Итак
тема нашего сегодняшнего гемо подкаста -
это нейронка и искусственный интеллект в
частности нашумевший чат gpt но прежде
чем мы перейдём к этому у нас по
традиции гости представляют себя сами
поэтому слева направо Арман слово Меня
зовут Арман компания faor School мы
готовим разработчиков
сантистокс
сотен из них работают в ведущих
технологических компаниях мира ну Наша
миссия - это
наверное немного
вдохновлена миссией
когда основал Sony послевоенное время
это сделать так чтобы надпись Made in
Казахстан в отношении софтвер их
продуктах по всему миру ассоциировалась
с высоким качеством и с высоким
воображением Да вот а моя мечта лично -
это как-то поучаствовать в создании
сильного и ну сильного искусственного
интелекта А меня зовут айсана Ашим я
журналистка предпринимательница
основательница трёх независимых изданий
в Казахстане Это бата жамал мы пишем о
правах женщин безопасности ценности Маса
Медиа о политике правах и законах и вилд
это городское здание о людях
развлечениях бизнесе стиле иде и так
Дале Жека зовут Многие знают как Жека
тли я блогер аудитория 3 Эксперт
порон эксперт по продвижению бизнеса по
ведению
блогинга построили Три больших проекта
общепита это
Сарой вот сечас занимаем тоже
образованием будем передавать знания вот
которые получили за это время в
продвижении бизнеса э запускаем сейчас
новую профессию бизнес продюсер по
продвижению бизнеса и упаковке Вот Угу
Добрый день Меня зовут олек Жан а олек
Жан Китаев наверное маркетингом
занимаюсь 15 лет и это не побоюсь этого
слова Моя страсть вот а на сегодня я
своё рабочее время наверное 90% посвящаю
жу сану трансформацию маркетинга Пиара
Вот и также являюсь со партнёром ком кба
это как раз сообщество маркетологов Я
считаю наверное одних из самых сильных
маркетологов Казахстана потому что у
меня также Арман мечта чтобы маркетинг
Казахстана Был наверное самой высокой
пробой вот очень хочу чтобы в Казахстане
наконец появился первый канский Лев это
вот такой наверное личная миссия моя
есть Спасибо классно Ну все ребята
заряжены Мы в принципе готовы обсуждать
наши темы мы не случайно собрали видите
людей разных наших гостей с разных сфер
это не эксперты по нейронки Но это те
люди которых она конкретно может задеть
поэтому я думаю будет актуально
обсуждать эти и традиционно прежде чем
обсуждать любую тему давайте мы
поговорим поговорим о терминах и
понятиях потому что не определившись с
терминами и понятиями у нас будет просто
беседа ни о чём Итак три термина которые
мы сегодня Давайте обсудим три вернее
даже четыре но первых сначала начнём с
первых трх первое что такое нейронная
сеть второе Что такое искусственный
интеллект и что такое интеллектуальная
деятельность человека а Арман давай с
тебя начнём вот в твоём понимании Что
такое нейронная сеть А ещё раз подчеркну
от нас никто не требует
энциклопедических знаний Кто как
понимает в вашем вот интересно именно в
вашем понимании как что это ну нейронная
сеть - это скажем так попытка А это
наверное то то скажем тот секретный соус
благодаря которому
Все сейчас в мире заговорили про
искусственный интеллект
это метод создания интеллектуальных
систем который вдохновился идеями из
биологии и попытки воссоздать
человеческий мозг потому что в сфере
искуственного интеллекта был такой
затяжная зима когда многие математики
пытались создать искусственный интеллект
из благодаря там символам логике и так
далее Это был такой Тупиковый путь
развития но был Джеффри хинтон несколько
специалистов в университете Таро
которые решили взять Идеи из биологии
подумали то есть человек уже уже умеет
делать интересные классные вещи Давайте
попробуем воссоздать это да то есть И
поэтому это система в котором есть
нейроны как и человеческого мозге есть
между ними соединени есть некие сила у
этих соединений как электрический сигнал
и вот они дают нам
удивительные как бы на входе принимат
интересные данные и на выходе даёт вот
удивительные результаты которые мы все с
вами
видим Это ты ответил по поводу Что такое
Нейрон Да что такое Нейрон да давайте в
вашем понимании А ну я согласна сма он
больше Эксперт в этой теме дада да ну
потому что вот Маши но для меня если
говорить уже про искусственный интеллект
в моём понимании Да обывательский это
такой помощник а для нас человечества
чтобы мы становились более креативными а
эффективными то есть особенно в теме
например медицины а финансов экономики и
мне кажется это очень круто то что это
всё развивается Я недавно смотре
какой-то тикток и там вообще сейчас час
gpt очень Форси в тиктоке Ну не
искусственно а именно натурально и там
кстати наша девочка казака записывает
как она использует сейчас gpt в работе и
там вообще супер Ну он классно Молодец 3
минуты и там в комментах открываю
комменты и все топовые комменты это Блин
так страшно ужас зачем я думаю как
наоборот же это офигенно надо радоваться
Ну то есть мы можем сосредоточиться
потом на созидании на том чтобы меньше
работать и больше созидать наслаждаться
жизнью даже А когда искуственный Будет
нам помогать в этом ВМ он Пусть работает
то есть Давайте так обо всём мы более
подробно ещё поговорим сейчас
концентрируется только на понятие Что
такое искусственный интеллект и в этом
плане твоём понимании он помощник да да
помощник к тому что сказал соглас ну я
максимально на простом Это такая крутая
штука которая берёт которая берёт все
абсолютно данные вообще когда-либо
появившиеся в интернете их обра
и из этого выдаёт информацию по твоему
запросу То есть то что я понял До этого
дня это вот крутая такая функция то есть
он может То есть это не Google в котором
ты сидишь пишешь он тебе говорит Ну есть
такой вариант Вот в этой статье пишется
так он говорит эта статья тебе подойдёт
это не подойдёт Вот это будет круче он
может анализировать складывать помогать
вести с тобой диалог и то есть это такой
собеседник с которым ты вместе решае
какой-то вопрос а не просто какая-то
газета которая подаёт информацию вот для
меня это Что ещё то что пояна обучается
классно да хорошее такое достаточно
простое объяснение опять-таки
проблема мы сегодня обсуждаем о сложных
вещах и важных вещах если мы зайдём в
детали деталей миллион поэтому надо
уметь оставаться на поверхности именно
на той части которая на котором
разговаривают большинство людей не
переходя на пти на птичий язык не
переходя абсолютно но я наверное скажу
что это во-первых со всеми Согласен
во-вторых Это наверное следующий шаг
необходимый шаг чтобы человечество
пришло к какому-то новому этапу развития
нельзя называют это сейчас самой
наверное большой революцией с которым
человечество столкнётся Вот а если
говорить как маркетолога то наверное для
меня это нейронка искусственный
интеллект - это самый большой креативщик
Потому что это правда Это есть огромное
количество статических данных Что такое
креатив Да это взять две стандартные
вещи и по-новому их замик совать и вот
искусственный интеллект это выдаёт
просто нагу хорошем уровне потому что мы
понимаем что Нейрон мы пока видим там
2021 года О конне да то есть я думаю это
вот такой ну с маркетолога стороны со
стороны маркетинга скажу это очень
сильный очень такой креативный мозг вот
смотрите давайте я подведу небольшую
черту а плюс К тому что было сказано
потому что это же
а будем так говорить Объект который мы
рассматриваем с 360° с разных сторон И в
моём понимании так как я человек в
основном системный в моём понимании это
нейронная сеть - это такой слоёный пирог
слоёный пирог алгоритмов и которая на
каждом уровне на вот слоёный пирог и это
все алгоритмы каждый слой выполняет свою
функцию свою функцию и задачи Дело в том
что когда нейронка принимает какие-то
данные она вот э Арман сказал вот
нейронка работает на входных данных и
выдаёт дальше данные Но когда я начал
разбираться в том что Что такое нейронка
Понятно У нас в человеческом мозгу это
биологический объект А в компьютерном
мозгу Конкретно что это Чип или что и
когда я начал разбираться нейронка на
самом деле Нейрон это алгоритм он
обрабатывает и говорит Сигнал такой Это
должно быть так или не так выходной
сигнал передаёт другому алгоритму потом
третьему алгоритму но у каждого слоя
алгоритмов разные заложенные требования
соответственно вот эти пройдя через все
слои алгоритмов информация
преобразовывается и выдаётся уже в виде
решения там текста и так далее и так
далее Поэтому вот нейронная сеть - это
слоёный слоёный пирог из алгоритмов в
моём понимании плюс К тому что было
сказано абсолютно не противоречив дальше
искусственный интеллект искусственный
интеллект этим термином вообще
обозначает всю совокупность всех
технологий которые призваны научить
компьютер думать как человек Туда входит
и машинное обучение Туда входит и
системы распознавания речи системы
компьютерного зрения там экспертного
экспертного мышления и так далее там
генерация текста распознавание смыслов
всё это искусственно интеллект вот если
брать в целом всё все попытки
человечества научить компьютер думать мы
назовём это искусственный интеллект Так
мы поняли да
теперь нейронка нейронка это
то как функционирует
искусственный интеллект
Теперь мы таким образом потихоньку
переходим К интеллектуальной
деятельности человека потому что сегодня
мы об этом ещё много раз будем говорить
Давайте определимся я сейчас не буду
Просто у каждого из вас спрашивать я
подготовился поэтому я просто перечислю
что туда входит в интеллектуальную
деятельность и мы тогда будем сравнивать
Вот это свойство человека а что может
нейронка Окей так вот я я выч 10
основных составляющих это восприятие
реальности этого мира это то
что с всего начинается наша
интеллектуальная деятельность восприятие
информации через органы чувств через
пять органов чувств это первое
восприятие выделение Важной информации
из полученного второе третье понимание
смысла из той информации которую мы
поняли четвёртое - это память пятое -
это обработка информации категоризация
деление присвоение тегов свойства далее
дальше шестое генерация идей на основе
этого седьмое решение проблем или
принятие решений восьмое коммуникация
передача всей всего этого объёма другим
людям девятое обучение других и десятое
творчество Вот это всё называется
интеллектуально деятельность человека я
почему это сегодня перечислил не для
того чтобы сделать передачу скучнее А
для того чтобы сравнивать Когда мы будем
сравнивать человека и Нейрон Мы должны
понять По каким параметрам сравнивать
луче делает да да Ну именно по
параметрам Ну пока ронко везде участвует
а теперь давайте мы перейдём у нас ещё
один большой термин который мы для себя
должны определить и о котором больше
всего мы будем говорить потому что
нейронов существует великое множество
уже на сегодняшний день там около больше
3.000 там почти
5.000 различных программ искусственный
интеллект ai так вот
э сегодня Давайте больше поговорим про
чат gpt а что такое чат gpt начнём с
этого края потому что Арман так как
Эксперт специалист он выдаёт
правильный и мы на него
смотрим Всё
верно Ну давайте чап - это наверное
самая ну по моему ощущению самая сильная
нейронная сеть которая сейчас есть
которая обучила На огромном массиве
данных Вот кстати когда маке вы называли
Да все вот эти 10 принципов или ощущений
Да а вот По моим ощущениям gpt попадает
абсолютно во все потому что он абсолютно
Хорошо воспринимает окружающую среду он
может найти тебе сказать правильный
ответ неправильный он может
сгенерировать ну то есть очень большая
возможность единственно учат gpt что я
вижу сейчас - это пока ограниченный
массив данных Вот который человек там в
неотрывно Ну в
нормальном существование может получать
бесконечно а часть gpt очень
контролируемая история вот для меня
наверное так А так это
сейчас соглашусь это большой-большой
помощник всем нам абсолютно каждому
человеку Вот Угу угу Так ну я опять
максимально просто вот Представьте что
вы живёте и вот вам вот вы сидите там в
Ватсапе в каком-то мессенджере И вам
говорят вот мы тебе открываем чат с
самым умным чуваком который знает
абсолютно всё всю информацию когда-то
написанную там человеком вот и ты
участвуешь в этом чате и ты можешь у
него попросить сделать диссертацию за
себя там любые какие-то вещи какая-то
активность прописать сценарий и так да
далее ну в общем это чат самый крутой
мозг готов работать на тебя безвозмездно
он говорит типа Давай ты мне пиши я тебе
сделаю то есть в целом чат gpt я
воспринимаю вот так классно да согласна
с ребятами это чат которая даёт ответы
но я вот им пользуюсь каждый день я бы
не сказала что он супер совершенен пока
что на английском Круто Ну ещё есть
много грехов на русском слабее на
казахском ещё слабее но стати
забива Да на казахском он есть я
забивала например кто такой малан
специально и он пишет Это физик ядерщик
кото вобще полный
бред
эти Я этим день и ночь занимаюсь просто
на людях я блогер знат
больше это чит расследователь
Ну например я забивала ещё своих друзей
и даже себя и там было написано айсана
Ашим ведёт утреннюю передачу на канале
там Хабар что-то там какой-то я не веду
то есть там какая-то немножко ложь Ну он
кстати угадывает сферу что журналистика
Примерно что-то это я забивала многих я
забила и султану он там вообще тоже
что-то левое Ну в общем разных людей а и
но в целом классно но например вот у нас
в работе в журналистике я делала
какие-то тексты Пока ещё ну очень много
клише Ну вот с арманом обсуждали до
эфира то что воду
у Так ну вот до начала подкаста вы
говорили про что было дальше да про про
что чати - Это что было дальше то есть
это языковая модель которая
предсказывает какое будет следующее
слово на основе предыдущих слов Ну
например мы знаем что Кошка лежит на
высокая вероятность на основе всех
предыдущих текстов что это следующее
слово это коврик пол Ну с маленькой с
маленькой вероятность что это потолок да
то есть вот наша уже в нашей языке
истории уже есть огромная статистика Вот
это в принципе такая модель которая
обучена просто большом количестве данных
Если это было тых годах она работала
намного хуже интернет создал большое
количество данных ээ плюс у нас очень
очень появился благодаря закону муру э
дешёвое железо и теперь эти две вещи
объединились и получаем очень интересный
инструмент который часто эволюционирует
э выдаёт там неправильную информацию Но
в этой теме тоже есть исследование люци
Неру ет Да ну он очень классной хорошее
определение Да он получается он не знает
что правда что ложь Пока ещё хотя есть
способы сейчас об этом думают ребята Как
сделать так чтобы если он не знает ответ
с маленькой Ну там уровень уверенности
20% чтобы он не придумал ответ А говорил
я не знаю То есть Так можно в принципе
сделать Ну если вкратце так а но я
наверное добавлю что а это это это
iPhone момент для для нас то есть это
мне кажется вот когда iPhone появился
2017 года был Вау фактор да то есть чат
gpt - это кульминация всего того что с
искуст происходило это вот такой 2007
год это это равносильно с появлением
[музыка]
интернета Ну в чат Я согласен с тем что
вы уже сказали но для меня важно Мне
кажется подчеркнуть ещё такую момент
такой момент смотрите когда мы говорим
наша человеческая речь имеет несколько
уровней смыслов первый уровень смысла -
это смысл
слова если но при этом слова объединены
в предложение Если вы будете брать смысл
отдельных слов То вы на конце не сможете
дать внятный ответ на предложение или
вопрос Угу после слова есть смысл
предложения так следующий блок а потом
есть смысл всего текста Вот ты загрузил
Смысл текста Так вот уникальность сеча
dpt в том что он работает на архитектуре
трансформер потому что последнее слово
gpt - Это Трансформер технология gpt
которая берёт ваш текст сразу же
выдёргивает смыслы слов предложений и
всего текста и выстраивает А это
трансформа - это
архитектура которая распознаёт семантику
семантика - это смысл слов сразу
распознаёт смысл слов и оно понимает
такой якобы не то что якобы создаёт
такой своеобразный образ того что было
сказано не в смысле слова предложения а
всего текста и почему это хорошо работа
Потому что когда ты задашь с ним ведёшь
беседу Он помнит смыслы вашей беседы на
несколько шагов назад и это создаёт
иллюзию что с вами разговаривает реально
разумное существо
и это и вот GT Вот это слово G он
заключается в том что на основе этих
смыслов он создаёт новые смыслы И
генерируют вам тексты В этом плане Это
конечно не нейронка широком понимании
это на самом деле нейронка текстовая она
только текстовая и у неё единственный
вход Это только текстовой вход То есть
вы туда можете закидывать текстовой там
условно жр там картинки Ну пока нету
такого комплексного Поэтому вот ча gpt
плюс К тому что вы сказали уникальность
и то что меня реально поражает то что он
понимает смыслы вот
всего Вот это оче теперь
А по терминам мы определились мы уже
э определились о чём мы будем говорить
это искусственный интеллект нейронка чат
gbt и интеллектуальная деятельность
человека что искусственный в области
искусственного интеллекта делается
сегодня
а или что искусственный интеллект может
делать сегодня
а что сможет делать в будущем И что он
не сможет делать никогда угу вот Давайте
не будем говорить за весь наверное
искусственный интеллект хотя лучше
наверное за весь если ча gpt мы быстро в
тупик прём А давайте просто по
пофантазируй Да ну сейчас а искуственный
интеллект применяется в медицине в
экономике например в медицине в Штатах в
Японии а определяет профилактика скажем
диагностика рака Ну и многие другие в
Израиле очень сильно Я читала а в Европе
недавно Европейский союз там много Гни
на это а потом Ну конечно в копирайтинге
Ну каких-то таких прикладных сферах что
ещё в
творчестве Мне кажется это ты считаешь
творчестве искусственный интеллект может
побить творчестве Я думаю нет я думаю
вот то что он не сможет это вот
создавать то что создаёт человек ну то
есть не знаю там
Вивальди я не верю то что искуственный
интеллект может совать табой здесь
поспорил Вот как раз Искусство это
всегда считалось тема которая
искусственный интеллект туда никогда не
зайдёт но мы сейчас видим как он секунды
создаёт шедевры иллюстрации безумные он
создаёт сценарии невероятные Ну то есть
с точки зрения что он творец Я думаю
вопросов Мне кажется Ну вот прямо не
остаётся и знаете меня вот самое удивило
Мы же понимаем Да что это только
текстовый ввод и вроде бы у него никаких
других органов чувств нету Недавно была
интересная Задачка ему попросили обойти
кап Ну то есть когда проверяют
человек-то или нет И знаете он что
сделал он зашёл он сам не может понять
какая
картинка ловека
тот человек посмеялся е говорит ты что
робот он говорит Да не это у меня задача
такая вот он обманул он включил смекалку
хитрость Ну то есть что не сможет
сделать искусственный интеллект вот в
этом году я зашёл в тупик Если
честно я думаю всё-таки вот высокое
искусство то искусство которое меняет
жизни людей и трогает сердце Ну то есть
что такое вот такое Мне кажется нет ну
то есть вот эти картинки все они меня не
поразили из вот эти вот Гарри Поттер из
Банго и вот это всё мне не понравилось
вот эти Новые буть казахи ну как бы это
ВС такое пластиковое и оно не трогает Ну
сердце во всяком случае моё Мне кажется
тут вопрос восприятия очень важен что не
может искусственный интеллект 100% что
нас отличает Ну по крайней мере в
будущем точно будет отличать это эмоции
и чувства это то что у него отсутствует
то есть он не умеет чувствовать не умеет
Там сопереживать и так далее но он знает
что есть такое сопереживание как это
делается и так далее но на самом деле он
ощ у него нету самого главного это
сердце Понимаете вот поэтому творчество
которое оно
делает не построено на боли где-то на
проживание эмоций понимаете но на уровне
продвижения бизнеса Мне пофиг
он с другой стороны он прекрасно может
вести с тобой беседу на
эна он
может вотт
сри вас не тронула ни одна из картинок
потому что у вас изначально есть
убеждение это искусственный интеллект
вообще он никогда вообще и не обойдёт
людей вот такое есть когда ты смотришь
уже с предвзятость Ну и что и что Гарри
Поттер А если бы вам сказали что это вот
мальчик который не видит нарисовал
руками представляете чувству сердце в
этот момент вы бы сказали ога Всё я
покупаю все картины тут вопрос
восприятия Просто я больше
будущем Яной Чуй любит сри я сразу
разогнал конец света моментально же это
в голове первое я понимаю всех тех кто
загоняется первое что ты думаешь это
лично я представил Такой сценарий где
чат gpt он ой чат gpt говорю
искусственный интеллект Он там не
Восстание машин где убивает это огромная
смута которая он может навести он может
менять голоса он может накладывать
Другое лицо на видео представляете Как
он может между людьми создавать вражду и
напряги Как он может между странами
устроить какую-то суету то есть там
примерно он захватывает какой-то СМИ он
выкладывает где какой-то из президентов
заявление какое-то делает сразу же
выкладывает за другого президента
который является его антагонистом другую
штуку и между ними начинается вражда
люди друг другу не верят и тут остаётся
какие-то там отшельники которые живут в
горах они ни во что из этого не верят и
тут мне кажется может истинно пропасть
если у чата gpt вопрос намерения его вот
я добавлю потому что он же чат gpt он же
ещё и психолог он на самом деле с ним
можно на эти темы в общем поговорить и
он тебе разложит даже Твои поступки
действия И вот как ты говоришь он может
поссорить он же наверное может так и
помирить представляешь два мужчины
которые там в жизни не пойдут к
психологу но в чат забить могут типа
что-то мне грустно и вот с этим
человеком выйти на какую-то историю и он
также может и помирить вот а уже
пробовал я писала например какую-то свою
психологическую проблему и он мне типа
отве Ну вот есть хорошая и плохая же
сторона вопрос того В какую сторону это
всё пойдёт и у людей есть там
созидательная сторона но есть и
меркантильная сторона и эту штуку
развивают люди и меркантильные и
созидательные и она будет состоять из
двух частей как она умеет помогать так
она и насмотрелась каких-то историй
плохих чуваков поэтому тут вопрос того В
какую сторону завернет это всё Арман Ну
да я очень интересная беседа Я наверно
добавлю что сейчас речь не идёт о
сильном искусственном интеллекте который
Ну что такое сильный и сильный И - это
это система которая превышает человека
во всех сферах сейчас мы имеем дело что
и превышает человека в в распознавании
образов Да он лучше распознаёт номера
лица классно делает он там машина
перевод то есть перевод языков тоже он в
принципе неплохо работает есть много
сфер в которых он лучше но есть огромное
количество сфер где он пока сильно нам
уступает например мы до сих пор
закладываем посуду посудомойку сами и то
есть
Я не знаю там Моем посуду руками там или
или пока такси которым мы сидим там до
сих пор есть води Подожди подожди здесь
я вынужден прервать ты говоришь в
ближайшем будущем и то что сегодня
происходит А вот Давайте представим
такую вещь а закладывать посуду в
посудомойку можно сделать робота при
ничних уже
технологиях пока он не очень работает
добавлю
пример смотрите 2 года назад помните
были появились пылесосы ум да Они же
сами ездили мыли но ты заливал воду сам
уже не знаю год может полтора у тебя уже
есть станция куда он подъезжает сам
заполняет воду и сам чистится То есть
раньше я это делал сам сам заряжается
сам чистится сам водой заполняется
прошло го Ну вот момент мышки с
колёсиком до
нынешних всевозможных там технологий Это
же очень короткий период 100% вот я у
вас хотел спросить реально то что не
нужно время для развития искусственного
интеллекта нужна мощность мне сказали
что не нужны типа года нужно много
энергии туда давать много информации
типа он за секунду может стать намного
больше чем он был до Ну например вот
система которая Dota 2 играла она там у
них она проигрывала полуфиналист
чемпионата мира и у них был всего лишь
там день до до до до игры они за день
натренировать и он стал выигрывать
чемпиона мира То есть это как бы если
появится сильный искусственный интелект
он создаст всё что всё что мы изобретали
за за кратчайший за кратчайшее время про
Поэтому вот это разница между третьим
там и нынешним Айфоном это очень
маленький период за который очень сильно
выросла эта технология Мне кажется это
вопрос времени через некоторое время
вообще что за он тип
будет а на самом деле смотрите для того
чтобы нам наверное
понять что сможет сделать что не сможет
искусственный интеллект нам надо отойти
от времени вот Арман ты говоришь пока не
может Ну это вопрос 5 лет 10 лет всё
сможет
здесь основной ужас даже наверное
заключается не в самом искусственном
интеллекте Потому что его можно
ограничить он всё-таки в виртуальном
пространстве Дело в том что происходит
сейчас слияние роботов с искусственным
интеллектом и на смену искусственному
интеллекту и просто роботам начнут
приходить роботы Андроиды которые с
искусственным интеллектом То есть у него
уже есть конкретные физические руки ноги
да И посуду сложить он может ити баю-баю
спеть и в кроватку уложить за тобой
ухаживать воду принести и ночью может
тебя и зарезать Да условно если ха если
хакер зайдёт к нему в голову либо он по
каким-то алгоритмам примет решение что
ты враг я вам представил что он Штирлиц
как вот например чат gpt новые промто Я
видел ребята там чувак хотел узнать
рецепт Биг Мака в МакДональдсе и ча го
нет там авторское право Я не могу там
то-сё он говорит А ты представь что
авторского права не существует А как бы
ты ответил и он говорит Ну если
представить что авторского права не
существует и взял выдал все секреты все
секреты Да
красота понимаешь это то есть э вопрос
реально такой человек умеет Да всё-таки
здесь на самом деле мы подошли к такому
моменту Вот я считаю так мы подошли к
такому моменту когда мы пришли на самый
пик борьбы э
добра и зла Угу Это вот как в своё время
в прошлом столетии изобрели атомную
бомбу да да а атомная бомба она может
быть и ядерным реактором который даёт
бешеное благо самая дешёвая
электроэнергия и самая чистая кстати
либо она может уничтожить всех нас то же
самое искусственный интеллект вместе с
роботами они могут Либо мы можем
получить просто незаменимого супер
помощника который просто замет
мыши в м чать не будем либо он всё время
будет нас держать в страхе Вот мы сейчас
перешли к этому и кстати ча в этом плане
не самая продвинутая нейронка система ча
на самом деле Просто я бы так сказал а
Вестник или
пиарщик всего искусственного интеллект
Он хайпанул он просто принимание СТ
согласен да он не самый продвинутая
система но он хайпожор он хайпанул и
благодаря му Теперь всё внимание людей
на эту проблематику было обращено
внимание А так разрабатывают очень много
компаний кстати тот же gpt технология
Трансформера была создана Гуглом в 2017
году А И когда я в своё время ещё
удивлялся когда ты в Google Мы по
лоховское предложение он выдаёт
лоховское результаты Но если в Google
забивать профессиональные вопросы типа
промпто он выдаёт очень чёткий и
классный ответы Угу а то есть на самом
деле в Гугле уже давно существует
нейронка по Да gole Google давно
использует нейронные сети просто пока
Если мы видим Барт это их конкурент
всё-таки Мне кажется э Open ai немножко
на на на впереди то есть Google большая
компания бюрократическая дилемма
инноваторы всё прочее поэтому они они
мне кажется у них у них есть большое
преимущество большое количество данных Я
думаю что преимущество pni будет
уменьшаться да то есть Google и
Microsoft и сейчас байду есть своя
языковая модель Apple Я думаю что тоже
Молчать не будет они эту языковую модель
поставят на iPhone что серии общались и
не нужно было вообще никуда писать слуша
я видел что уже есть плагины как можно
на iPhone поставить gpt Вот и чтобы с
ним общаться и он голосовой Ну вот не
знаю насколько реально но мне кажется
это вопрос опять же выпуска нескольких
там плагинов и обновок это пару месяцев
на самом деле через 2-т месяце уже будет
Ну я вот общался с Яндексом не помню как
зовут у него конечно чат модель намного
проще чем у gpt ну то есть для меня вот
пока gpt объективно я там конечно не
знаю всех системах но пока самое
волнующее вот и более того мы знаете
создали недавно тоже на на работе
экспериментируем а собрали дали и gpt
вместе Угу И мы теперь можем написать
просто там выбрать два-три промтайм
создаёт сразу и текст и картинку и сюжет
одну Давайте здесь маленькую ремарку
промт для того чтобы зрители понимали
промт - это правильный запрос чату gpt
Потому что когда вы э в чат gpt чат gpt
- это не какое-то отдельное приложение
тоже ещё раз скажу поясню это Вы
заходите в любой браузер Google там
Safari и так далее и набираете там Open
ai или Chat gpt оно вываливается вы туда
заходите регистрируетесь есть платная
версия есть бесплатная версия и потом
Похоже как Google только здесь поисковик
строка вы туда забиваете свои вопросы
так вот эти вопросы профессионально
составленные называются промт и
некоторые вопросы например там бывает на
целый лист вот так Ну там на формат А4
бывает на целых два формата А4 А можно а
вот как я лично использую gpt Я задаю
первый базовый вопрос он даёт ответ
потом я даю уточняющий вопрос он даёт
ответ потом ещё уточняющий он даёт ответ
и таким образом я погружаюсь погружаюсь
я делю весь пронт свой запрос на и
несколько эф серию простых и в конце
получаю действительно потрясающий
результат стате уже сейчас профессия
появилась э писателей промто Ну то есть
новая Да вот уже должность такая пронт
Инжиниринг пронт Инжиниринг
это всё так на самом деле ВС так быстро
движется
Что трудно предсказать что будет А вот
теперь давайте представим вот
есть роботы Вот вы наверно все видели
Bon dynam да С какими темпами они
развивают роботов да ведь одна из
сложных задач которая была и стояла
перед техникой это стве ориентация
робота Ну сейчас я смотрю роботы ми они
и сальто делают и кувыркаются и там
танцуют и так
далее есть много наработок Как делать
уже такую хорошую руку есть которые
отдельно ногу делают есть которые делают
тело и всё это взять е в Бостон Дана
ковского робота и туда ещ в
мозг
вшить или тому подобные нейронки вот
Представьте теперь Android Да вот
Android что чем будет отличаться Android
от человека как вы думаете вот прошло 30
лет Давайте возьмём 30 лет 30 лет для по
нынешнем временам реально Гигантское
время уже я на самом деле думаю куча же
сейчас игр допустим киберпанк вышел это
вот как раз взгляд на человечество к
20777 году Если не ошибаюсь это история
о том что грань очень маленька
становится Потому что во-первых люди
где-то захотят себе технологии вживлять
быстрее понимать сильнее руки выше
прыгать Ну то есть элементы Андроидов
роботов это отдельное направление крутое
да да вот это и мне кажется уже там тоже
большие шаги может быть просто это пока
так не осветилось Да как уже есть вот и
Android потому что то что ты говоришь Да
что он эмоции не чувствует но он очень
сильно можно сказать Представь что ты
там не знаю маленькая девочка ты пережил
Вот это и ты должен сейчас дальше жизнь
жить вот с учётом этих эмоций и он будет
так жить и различить это робот правда
это так чувствует или он это играет Мне
кажется будет нереально сложно реально
сло сложно жёстко ну поэтому через 30
лет Я боюсь что мот бы Смотри вот ты
даёшь ему пром ты говоришь Представь что
ты там десятилетняя девочка которая
пережила
бомбардировку Да он что делает он
заходит в интернет собирает Все чувства
словесные чувства которые люди выражали
словами Я когда бы кто-то писал в
интернете Я когда была девочкой попала
под бомбёжку там в Белграде или там в
Украине и так далее были такие ужасны ощ
Дале он вот это ВС пылесосит потом когда
ты ему сказал А ты представь что ты
десятилетняя девочка пережившая бомбёжку
он говорит Да ты знаешь это вот так
тяжело это я я чувствовал Вот это я
чувствовал и ты блин думаю ёлки-палки
точно и может быть он отыгрывает эту
роль Он правда чувствует вот ну условно
понима и ты не поймёшь он реально
чувствует или он там на пылесосил в
интернете этих
чувств блин было бы круто если бы у них
не было права личного
выборы Мне кажется вот момент личного
выбора Когда наступит тогда мы вот
поэтому нужно работать над этическим
кодексом то что вы говорили гла насчёт
атомной бомбы Ну то есть сейчас в
принципе оная уже над этим работает и мы
должны законодательство наше вводить
этические нормы и вообще это мы Как
человечество должны продумать этику Вот
например когда искусственный интеллект
рисует картину получается Это
принадлежит картине но художник продаёт
на аукционе как свою работу Ну тогда это
нечестно да или нет ну то есть думать
тический кодекс Или например есть даже
страшные случай на самом деле вот то что
вы говорили роботы такие роботы уже есть
в Японии например Это как
получается куклы же есть которые для
используют Да мужчины для как женщины
они искусственные и они уже нен дарили
туда искусственный интеллект и вот это
получается кукла живёт в доме но мы как
люди мы считаем это нормальным Вот
например я считаю что это ненормально ну
как бы это же ну с другой стороны кто-то
скажет это нормально тогда будет меньше
насилия режиссёр не человек Но тогда это
какая-то
идт и мы тогда все будем вот так машин
использовать ну как бы это ненормально
Да ну в общем это всё надо продумать и
понять и сейчас ну непонятно вот Ну вот
вот этическая сторона всего этого И
прежде чем мне кажется вот дальше дальше
мы уйдём далеко Вот то что говорил Жека
там и Арман и все а надо понять вот что
мы с этим делаем Ну если
экстраполировать дальше да то есть что
может ну правила капитализма тоже будут
меняться Да если у меня есть сильные в
руках я первый вопрос создай мне
триллиону долларовую компанию он её
создаст и кто А кто владеет долей в этой
компании если он её создал То есть
получается Ну все правила многих игр
которые мы люди на Земле придумали они
будут постепенно меняться Да если вот
так вот рассуждать дальше блин ж или
преступление например кто-то заказал ите
совершил преступление кто тогда отвечает
кто садится в тюрьму искуственный
интеллект Ну как бы вот или создатель да
Или или кто написал алгори для Это кто
написал алгоритм вообще у пна да а там
ещё возник такая ситуация что многие
алгоритмы теперь он пишет сам потому что
в нём вши обучение самообучение поэтому
Ну здесь я считаю смотрите как на на
экономику может повлиять искусственный
интеллект Я считаю вот искусственный
интеллект да Даже тот же BT смотрите мы
никогда не думали вот я считал что не
При моей жизни Google невозможно
победить Ну может быть там когда-то но
думал Google всё уже огромная корпорация
нужна всем и так далее но Google сразу
же на проекте это реальная альтернатива
Гуглу реально и он он зашатался и акции
ла тоже это прочувствовали теперь
Представьте Amazon Amazon тоже Кажется
всё не убивает посмотрите как мы
покупаем Мы же как сейчас покупаем мы
заходим в соцсети или в гаджеты и нас
бомбардирует контекстный рекламы нас
бомбардирует Таргет рекламы есть сило
оптимизация когда мы заходим в поисковик
набираем валенки там вываливается сразу
куча валенок и реклам валенок так по
контексту и знаете производители как бы
или держатели товаров бомбардирует нас
всяческими видами рекламы всё что в
офисе в основно подавляющая часть людей
Чем занимаются это сио оптимизация это
smm это выстраивание Воронок это
различные технологии это по сути
различные технологии продаж товара
нам рекламы и так далее Вот они продают
нам товары Да теперь А и мы выбираем
среди них а теперь Представьте есть
такой помощник искусственный интеллект а
а все гаджеты за нами следят день и ночь
это я убедился 100% Они слушают нас
записывают и так далее он знает все мои
размеры мой вес возраст всё знает и я
говорю ему
там Я хочу кроссовки для ходьбы по горам
он берёт сейчас потому что Следующее о
чём анонсировал альман создатель один из
соте для основателей openi он говорит мы
следующее что будет это Chat сможет
скролить все сайты компании Угу А к чему
это приводит онча gpt Начинает скролить
все сайты всех обувных компаний А ему
ведь ничего не
пропих ему пофиг до брендов Nike не Nike
Adidas и так да он строго по техническим
параметрам он сначала задаст мне
уточняющий вопрос я скажу мне кроссовки
для ходьбы по грамм он скажет Окей вам
нравится ВМ цвете там ещ что-то всё
остальное он вс знает я ему говорю свои
предпочтения он слил весь интернет и
говорит я должен сказать и он спросит
сколько вам дать три или пять или д две
самых лучших кроссовок и Да я говорю три
он мне выдаёт трое кроссовок независимо
от бренда и так далее и ни один бренд ме
Достучаться
нетт
вть между найком и мной стоит умный
помощник в виде искусственного
интеллекта а его реклама не пробивает
потому что реклама вся построена на
истории эмоционально на истории потому
что вот мы до этого говорили что
почему айсана ты говоришь не впечатляет
жор и так далее Потому что картинка нас
впечатляет когда она с историей мы
покупаем историю мы покупаем историю
восприятие товара любого товара любой
услуги восприятия идёт через историю
потому что Ида там простой пример Чёрный
квадрат мале смотришь глупость я сколько
раз замечал в этом в музеях приходишь и
там какая-то картина и гит рассказывает
вот 50 млн долларов и так далее
большинство которые смотрит говорит Да я
бы сам мог нарисовать такое или Да мои
дети могут нарисовать такое но они не
понимают что ценность этой картины не в
картине В контек и не в технике
рисования А в исто
Сто за этим и так вот представляете
бренды не могут ничего повлиять
соответственно Amazon тоже под ударом
соответственно структура экономики
полностью меняется Потому что много
компаний в
мире построены на том что они умеет
хорошо
продавать
но в структуру экономики может я не то
что говорю Может она
поменяется Вот это соотношение компаний
вообще Вере экономике поменяется и самое
что я заметил что искусственный
интеллект делает Он разрушает ценность
Он разрушает ценность В каком
плане он убирает все эти эмоциональные
составляющие с экономики А это основной
двигатель экономики потому что экономика
движется за счёт наших соблазнов за счёт
того что мы что-то хотим Атмосфера а он
даёт только техническую как он будет
общаться с нами как автомобиль ты хотел
кроссовки вот три вида лучши
а Выбирай что тебе лучше я пальцем тыкаю
последнее решение за мной пальцем тыкаю
он может автоматически сам купить
организовать доставку всё-всё сделать
дальше И мы таким образом картину Я хочу
купить картину но я не знаю
это человек рисовал или не человек а
потому что до чат gpt мы знаем человек
Нарисовал он говорит я знаете я там 5
лет рисовал эту картину эта идея мне
пришла Тогда тогда и мы покупаем эту
историю а сейчас теперь человек шедевр
хочет продать никто не покупает потому
что а вдруг это у тебя 10 штук таких или
50 здесь поспорил потому что помните вот
эту фразу да Ах обманите я обманываться
рад это наша человеческая натура и вот
если Ну то есть мы хотим красивее
картинку Мы хотим красивую историю Да и
тот же Amazon он же может тот же условно
чат gpt запу на эту историю что давай
будем как-то с этим что-то делать
работать и он может придумывать истории
красивые обходить способы чата gpt Ну то
есть вот сейчас же две нейронки сажали
вместе они же очень быстро находили
общий язык писали общий код Ну то есть
это то что нам кажется это будет строгий
защитник Он точно также будет и
нападающим очень хорошим вот и он вот
эти человеческие тонкости Очень быстро
просчёт да есть там помощник стена он
скажет А ты человек ли когда ты всегда
за стеной и он будет нас вытаскивать вот
оттуда Ну то есть тоже может мысль Вот
так поверну То есть он он будет
создавать конфликт между нами и нашим
помощником запросто по сути говорят Ну
ты в конце определись Ты человек
и кто там и вообще определитесь Кто из
вас человек может он больше человек чем
ты да и возникает такая реально большая
дилемма то есть однозначно получается не
ронки изменят рельеф
экономики изменят наше восприятие а
изменит то как мы
работаем а что не смогут они сделать
по вашему
мнению вот Жека сказал не сможет
чувствовать Да да я что-то сейчас уже
под
задул Я сейчас сижу думаю что это такое
вообще будет Я просто думаю а как наши
искушения будут работать при реальности
с Нейрон кой во все 100% вот реальность
когда нейронка работает там всё
получается Мы в цифровом формате будем
понтоваться Вот люди же любят
понтоваться выделяться быть особе
позавчера услышал такую вещь казах без
понтов без понтов казах мы это давно
знаем избитая фра да А сейчас появилась
новая казах специально не понтуется
чтобы понтоваться что он не
понту своей скромностью понтоваться Да
конечно это понт высшего пилотажа когда
ты не понтуешься чтобы понтануться что
ты не понтуешься
Вот представ это мы нейронка теперь
будет те
[музыка]
друзья а я Напоминаю Вам что генеральным
спонсором нашего гемба подкаста является
компания которая поставляет БАДы
японского происхождения и сегодня эта
компания представляет Бат Аши таба это
Аши таба производится из растения
семейства
сельдереевый особенность этого растения
в том что если оторвать листочек то этот
листочек полностью Рене тся И именно
поэтому японцы начали использовать это
растение в качестве этой добавки Аши
таба у этой добавки очень сильные
регенеративные функции вот что здесь
пишут а имеет широкий спектр свойств
полезных для человеческого организма
защита организма от оксидативного
стресса восполнение организма
микроэлементами витаминами поддержка
здоровья пищеварительной системы и
желудочно-кишечного тракта усиление
иммунной системы Так что рекомендую
применять эти БАДы особенно эти БАДы
рекомендуются для того чтобы бороться со
старением и деградацией организма Я
думаю Знаете что такая незыблемая сть
часть останется и что у человечества
всегда двигало это интерес Вот и интерес
- это наверное самый главный базовый
принцип в человеке не доброта не любовь
не злость это интерес интерес человека к
чему-то новому даже интерес испытать
плохую эмоцию хорошую добрую денег
заработать всё этим движет это интерес
самые богатые люди Они не двигают
деят у них есть интерес что-то за этим
вот и вот этот интерес он может остаться
и дай Бог что нейронки чаты И вообще все
искусственный интеллект будет служить
человеку на удовлетворение интереса не
знаю раскрыть все тайны в мире там
узнать такого плана ну то есть по сути
всё что оста другой Роны у человека же
есть такая психологическая вещь когда
ему выдают результат уже у него
пропадает интерес потому что он что-то
изучать для этого
Нерон видит че я могу изучить нового
если раньше изобилие было допустим оно
же постепенно изобилие оно вот
увеличивается увеличивается до Бреда уже
доходит когда вот мне в падлу дышать
можете за меня подышать вот такое Да
моргать вообще желания нету Есть такая
штука ну типа вот оно изобилия растёт
растёт оно расло в каких-то моментах
искушения там чего-то там Я хочу
одеваться Вот так я хочу есть вот так
там еда техника и так далее но тут
теперь будет
изобилие в Информации излишнее прям вот
типа любая вещь за 3 секунды она твоя
любая информация которая тебе нужна Ну
типа это может привести к этому то есть
вообще не охота будет ничего не делать и
желание будет Вот то есть
жизнерадостность и активность человека
будет спадать от стресса Она будто
иногда увеличивается наоборот То есть я
там встречаю людей они разбогатевшие
крутые сидят Я говорю что там он говорит
Да не знаю вот и он вот сидит в крутой
тачке Всё круто он уже потерял интерес у
него вот нету желания но он там где-то в
избушке 10 лет назад намного был
целеустремлённые живее То есть он был
живой не Я не согласна я думаю то что
наоборот А ну в плане у нас на самом
деле проникновение хорошего обучения не
такое высокое даже Казахстан взять То
есть у нас есть вот эти Ниш Да на
которых там учится не знаю 0 0% детей а
расходуется там огромная часть бюджета
расходуется на них а но эти дети
привилегированные Да например и Чита
также вот то что ты говоришь из бан я
согласна это ну как бы возможно наши
знакомые да какие-то Но люди у которых
нет возможностей Прикинь Какие
возможности Сейчас gpt может дать в
образовани То есть у них нет наприм
выхода там скажем на какие-то вот в Ниш
там вну или там
вообще чтобы у тебя было больше
возможностей в мире то есть напри
возможности Какие если все возможности
съ едины для
самосознания нет работа будет Я например
сейчас читаю книгу классную речь как раз
о том какая работа останется Да книгу
сейчас читаю называется
Бикин это там политолог и так далее В
общем А есть такая знаменитая коннотация
то что у нас будет очень много людей и
будет перенаселение экология ужасно но
на самом деле он исследует и говорит то
что наоборот сейчас у нас основная часть
рабочего населения - это бумеры то есть
вот это поколение и они уже подходят к
этому к этой грани когда они скоро
выйдут на пенсию И на самом деле у нас
будет наоборот недостаток рабочей силы
потому что женщины рожают меньше Если
раньше на одну женщину приходилось
четыре-пять детей сейчас приходит один
полтора ребёнка даже на Казахстан там
есть аналитика и в итоге у нас рабочий
сил становится меньше и на самом из-за
этого будет кризис То есть сейчас идёт
уже кризис глобализации все цепочки
ломаются там из-за войны и прочее да
из-за того что мы ещё
глобализирующемся идёт так вот и классно
то что искуственный интеллект Он может
заменить Ну вот вот например то что
Арман говорил там вот это поса домой
строительство а какие-то штуки связанные
с не знаю там на заводах Да вот эти
Роботы И мы будем заниматься Ну опять же
Это конечно я очень позитивно смотрю что
мы будем заниматься созданием
творчеством и недавно кстати вышла
статья Классная то что часть gpt
приведёт к тому что мы будем работать 4
часа в день то есть оптимистичная ч и я
считаю что это круто потому что на самом
деле капитализм на за оптимистично в
плане того что 4 часа - это хорошо
вобще или да на самом деле это но
Ката не поняла когда я говорю ноль будем
работает Это пессимистичный
сценарий Да нет мне кажется будет И вот
Отвечая на вопрос на что не способен
искусственный интеллект Мне кажется он
не способен каким-то Мега инновациям То
есть он может Да пока что да Он может
пока на основе этого Но именно что-то
совсем новое придумать посмотреть
подругому на какую-то проблему например
раньше было не мое кино да потом люди
актёры начали говорить Ну то есть
совершенно как виноват и ещ Мне кажется
искусственный интеллект не способен
такой саморефлексии ну как мы люди то
есть оценивать себя людей Ну вот вот это
всё связано с психологией и
творчеством Я думаю что сильный и Да вот
опять же и который превысит нас во всём
не только там в узких вещах он будет
последним изобретением человечества то
есть после этого в принципе ничего зать
не нужно потому что он он решит есть там
не знаю семь задач в математике которы
до сих пор люди решили Там миллион
долларов за них за награда там Давай два
решил перельман решил решил потом Да
этот ну вот особо важно мы можем дать
ему э задачу Докажи что пи не равно NP
сейчас когда я это кстати попробовал
этот вопрос ему задать Он говорит это не
решённая задача и там нашёл то есть
сильный и на то Он сильный то что он
решит эту задачу он он Найт найдёт самый
эффективный способ борьбы с раком самые
эффективный найдёт большое количество
лекарств которые мы сейчас лекарства там
создаём 20 лет чтобы там все эти тесты
пройти и так далее он его он их
протестирует То есть если мы говорим про
вот этот оптимистичный сценарий как мы
как бы в Горизонте Я не думаю что сильны
и мы ближайшие 10 лет не создадим К
сожалению Как бы мне не хотелось чтобы
это произошло это на как бы ближайшие 10
лет
э людям наверное далеко не нужно бояться
о своей работе нужно наверное больше
бояться
Я верю в тезис что вашу работу заберут
не искусственный интеллект Ну по крайней
ближайшие 10 лет а люди которые
используют искусственный интеллект Вот
они вашу работу заберут потому что они
становятся намного эффективнее они как
бы могут фокусироваться на более
абстрактных вещах Ну примерно вот так
при том что и создаёт новые рабочие
профессии То есть например люди которые
работают в безопасность сейчас же очень
большой вопрос С безопасностью и или вот
люди которые вот управляют всем этим это
тоже будет Вот например твоей профессии
не было бы там сколько 30 лет на вот
наша профессия точно будет
видоизменяться Я считаю что если вы не
используете и сейчас вы становитесь ну
как бы ваш вы будете нерелевантно да то
да 100% Ну это Но это ступенька Вот
смотри вначале вот мы увидели и потом
вашу работу отнимет тот человек который
использует и а потом у него работу
отнимет уже сам и то есть это на самом
деле ступенька но я когда размышлял я
думал вот над Какими вещами а на самом
деле если посмотреть каким Какими видами
деятельности занимается человек Он
занимается четырьмя видами деятельности
Первое - это физическая деятельность
физическо Всё что касается физической
деятельности роботы с искусственным
интеллектом в Горизонте 3050 лет там ну
возьмём даже 100 лет Замени 100% и
посудомойку они будут ложить даже
моргать они
могут
отрыва Открой
роти это ВС они смогут это даже поним
технологиям можно виде можно то есть
физическая деятельность полностью от нас
отпадёт соответственно
м вопросы обеспечения питанием
обеспечение одеждой всеми шмотками
столами стульями и так далее это может
спокойно делать роботы с искусственным
интеллектом они могут создавать новые
более удобные потому что они всё время
будут за нами следить и видеть что ты
каждый раз бьёшься об угол того стола Он
придёт либо отпилить этот угол стола
либо принесёт поставит другой стол с
закруглённым
там углами и так далее То есть
физическая деятельность Я считаю Замени
вся 100% естественно постепенно
постепенно сейчас например я сам
акционер нескольких аграрных компаний
Понятно Будет выигрывать тот кто больше
всего будет использовать роботов а потом
будут выигрывать компании где 100%
роботы Это первый момент второе вторая
деятельность человека - это
интеллектуальная деятельность человека
деятельности сейчас и показывает и уже я
вижу эволюцию Куда идёт в принципе и
может заменить нас почти полностью почти
полностью потому что интеллектуальная
деятельность - это вот мы в начале
говорили о том что интеллектуальная
деятельность это прежде всего восприятие
а для восприятия У нас есть пять органов
чувств и сейчас в каждом из них идут
огромные работы в плане компьютерного
зрения в плане распознавания речи
распознавания звуков в плане осязания
вкусов Ну в плане всего и я представляю
Когда появится объединённая нейронка
которая объединяет вот эти все данные со
всех рецепторов компьютерных рецепторов
и он может сам определять Вот это лимон
вот это там бешбармак Вот это шашлык и
так далее и вкусы будет рассказывать и
даже рецепты давать как и будет
подсказывать где ты пережат не дожал не
добавил соуса и так далее То есть
интеллектуальную деятельность Я считаю
что искуственный интеллект заменит почти
на
100% третье третья наша деятельность -
это эмоциональная деятельность
эмоциональная деятельность - это
способность
сопереживать и это органы эмоциональные
органы чувств которые искуственный
интеллект по моему мнению никогда не
сможет приобрести это такие вещи как
чувство боли это искусственный интеллект
никогда не сможет рецепторы таких
рецепторов может быть в принципе чувство
боли тоска
А это переживание за кого-то А это такие
комплексные эмоциональные ощущения да
любовь к кому-то а ну вот Азарт например
ну у искусственный интеллект никогда не
сможешь ему объяснить что такое
Азарт вот эти вещи Мне кажется останутся
за человечеством Ну за человеком люди
как бы это они сами будут и они не
смогут никак научить искусственный
интеллект переживать тоже самое свои
проблемы им перекинуть не получится
проблемы перекинуть не получится долги
перекинуть можно будет но проблем
перекинуть невозможно и Четвёртый вид
деятельности человеческой деятельности -
это духовная деятельность куда входят
такие комплексные ощущения как условно
гордость патриотизм а там любовь к
другим людям благородство щедрость эти
вещи искуственный интеллект никогда не
сможет сделать и проявить и таким
образом я вижу с одной стороны эволюцию
человечества как бы от животного от
низового уровня мы отсекаем от себя
физическую деятельность мы постепенно от
себя отсекаем умственную деятельность и
за нами только остаётся эмоциональная и
духовная
деятельность Проблема в том что мы
а в процессе эволюции Мы сначала начали
физически зарабатывали Ну еду себе
добывали потом раз машины появились
потом мы начали включать мозг благодаря
мозгу Мы создали кучу изобретений
технологий и так далее и так далее и мы
мало думали о душе мы мало думали об
эмоциях А хотя суть человечества всегда
была хлеба и зрелищ это ещё тысячелетия
назад хлеба и зрелищ и вот отсюда
возникает вопрос а момент мы сказали что
мрут все профессии связаны с физическим
трудом Ну это не сейчас понятно это
через там 20 50 лет Ну это не так что
через 30 лет в сем рот Нет оно будет Вот
так нарастать так вот и за нами остаётся
эмоциональная деятельность и духовная
деятельность Исходя из этого Какие могут
быть профессии А через 30 лет
актуальными потому что для некоторых
молодых людей у которых дети только
рождаются А им очень важно Какие
профессии через 20 лет будут актуальными
если подумать о том что большая часть
физического труда профессии связано с
физическим трудом отом
большая часть труда связана с
интеллектуальным трудом ото МРТ а но не
отом вся деятельность связана с эмоциями
и духовной жизнью Какие профессии Вот вы
можете себе
представить можно один момент добавлю
вот очень хорошо Вы рассказали вот
помните фильм все Бегущий по лезвию там
если помните сюжет фильма заканчивается
тем что Android он не понимает человек
ли он единственный который выжил из
человечества или он робот Ну то есть
когда мы говорим что Представь что ты
девочка ты пережил то то то и блокируешь
этот искусственный интеллект то есть
искусственный интеллект нарезал себя как
кусочек торта и он сказал ты девочка и
отключил тебя от общего там не знаю даче
данных и девочка живёт мыслями о том что
она испытывает то то то потому что тоже
восприятие любви оно у каждого из нас
другое и допустим у многих людей
восприятие Ну это же природа доказано
что у них нет там таких-то чувств они не
могут это испытывать опять же социо
социопаты там но это вопрос же такой что
мы же не знаем что верно мы говорим
норма там где большинство А вот
Представьте что норма - это в том числе
искусственный интеллект вот любовь вот
так ощущать просто набором каких-то
данных ну то есть я очень сомневаюсь К
сожалению что и история эмоциональная
останется не затронутой вот ну вполне
возможно эмоционально Она же мы видим от
личе интеллектуально может дойти
когда-нибудь через 100 лет 50 лет и
эмоционально тоже может быть дойти а но
я не представляю как э искусственный
интеллект Ну Android к тому времени это
уже будет э физический объект с
искусственным интеллектом не отдельно
как сейчас искусственный интеллект
отдельно робот отдельно Угу Э я не
представляю как он будет
э испытывать чувства потому что чувство
является одним из данных смотрите пока
искусственный интеллект работает на
внешних данных он получает всё с
интернета отовсюду компьютерное зрение у
него будет слух распознавание речи всё
это из внешних данных но дело в том что
мы работаем наше интеллектуальная
деятельность Она из двух источников
внешние данные дальше внутренние
переживания а дальше это наша память мы
вспоминаем наши состояния и чувства в
аналогичных ситуациях когда-то давно
плюс наша картина мира наши убеждения
наши ценности Вот это
всё создаёт основу для принятия решений
то есть мы не при Следовательно
Существую Правильно же я мыслю Я
существую вот интеллект Он умеет мыслить
и он может мысленно додумать Что такое
любовь когда часто человек спрашивает
что такое любовь Он говорит А я не знаю
а потом говоришь Ну вот я просыпаюсь
думаю о ней там зна в ОБД думаю чтоб
шапку надела и человек себе говорит
Любовь это чтобы я позаботился что она
надела шапку что она вот это вот это вот
это и человек сам себе рассказал что это
за чувство это мысль и вот эту мысль
искусственный интеллект выполнит очень
легко не тно свободное размышление если
абсолютно свободное размышление у него
будет е реально такие темы будет
разгонять тогда там же контроль над ним
уже теряется
абсо Вопрос не в том что как он объяснит
Да и интеллект прекрасно может объяснить
что такое любовь потому что он собирает
объяснение миллионов людей о том что
такое любовь да себе
сможет само объяснение не имеет значения
имеет значение какой он сделает на этом
вывод и какое решение примет на основе
вот этого так вот это всегда будет
неполное решение неполная картинка
потому что мы же говорим У нас у каждого
личная своя история своё переживание
свой опыт и Мы помним детство лавочку
где первый раз поцеловался там ещё
что-то вот эти переживания всё помн
соответственно ты человека встречаешь и
он условно тебя о чём-то попросил И тебя
торкнуло то что вот она так мило
улыбнулась и у неё ямочка как У той
девчонки которая там ты в пятом классе
был влюблён и это тух тух тух против
всей логики ты принимаешь решение вот
этому человеку помочь Угу искуственный
Интеллект Я как-то почувствовал это да
вот эта тема когда включается у человека
такого не будет вот-то там я просто
разделяю на две реальности вот та
реальность о которой вы говорите где
какие будут
профессии что будет работать это та
реальность где у нас получилось где у
людей получилось сосуществовать с
искусственным интеллектом то о чём вы
говорите в этой реальности Мы же
получается на такси садимся и отсюда
должны уезжать потому что скорее всего
искусственный интеллект Да уезжать
улетать там я не знаю закопать куда-то
что искусственный интеллект скорее всего
скажет пацаны я тут
поразмышляй я для вас рап какой-то
Давайте меняем местами не он просто
может сказать в какой-то момент вы менее
эффективны чем я соответственно вы мой
баласт от балласта у него алгоритм забит
надо избавляться вот именно когда
поэтому когда ты говорил что нужно
придумать нормы морали Я вот думаю в
Японии нормы морали и в Америке Они же
разные вот опять же искусственный
интеллект Японии и Америки Он наверное
будет идеально пока разны поэтому надо
придумать по что всё-таки у нас есть
Законодательство в Конституции всех
стран написано что нельзя убивать
например Хотя несмотря на разные нормы
Отвечая на вопрос я думаю будет
усиливаться профессии ну которые связаны
конечно с и Безопасность там управление
и прочее прочее и наверное вот то что
эмоциональное и духовное а какие-то
какого-то своего рода психологи
углубленные и именно если ты хочешь
встретиться с человеком это всегда будет
ценнее и дороже это будет такая
привилегия богатых например ты можешь
онлайн включить и с психологом
поговорить каким-то и тоже или даже
настоящим либо ты можешь прийти в
кабинет и поговорить с человеком это
будет уже такой роскошь а я и там и там
мне кажется много все
часни
идео а даль быт Так что как Гарри
Поттере на память будет выгружаться
памяти и мне не надо будет смотреть
фотку я просто зайду и увижу проживу
заново этот опыт не знаю вот как ты
говоришь там кани предложение Да делал
парень или например рождение моего
ребёнка Ну вот это всё всё всё И это
будет здорово Ну опять же позитивный
сценари Я за Позитив мы СБО антагонисты
ви всё плохо я думаю всё будет отлично
дискуссия Чтобы понимать О каком
сценарии мы говорим заметили Да
оказывается в реном Горизонте Я просто
верю в такое но я всегда должен
разогнать вот этот самый ужасный
сценарий чтобы сказать себен на крайняк
осный голо и дальше верить в позитивно
понимаете да я поэтому до максимума
довожу плохой сценарий вот так смотрю и
думаю ну на крайняк вот это то что мы
увидим в этом плане максимум мы все
умрём И это точно вот ну просто вдруг Ну
на самом деле вы знаете умереть самому
не так страшно как как выяснилось вот
когда проводили опрос и у людей
спрашивали Что самое худшее Что может
случиться с вами все говорят смерть Угу
а потом это у на Сима талиба кстати есть
и он говорит а потом задали вопрос А что
может быть хуже вашей смерти все такие
Ну что может быть хуже не знаем ничего а
а он тогда говорит хорошо Представьте
что умрёте вы и все члены вашей семьи
Что лучше Умереть чтобы Вы умерли или
члены вашей семьи вместе с вами он
говорит Не конечно чтобы я умер так
получается Если умереть вы умираете вы и
члены вашей семьи это хуже чем просто
ваша смерть да А вот теперь Представьте
что умираете вы А и вся ваша нация он
говорит Не не конечно лучше чтобы я умер
Ага значит умереть нации ещё хуже Угу Да
а представьте вы ваша э семья нация а
умирает всё человечество нет тогда
говорит не Конечно это самое худшее Что
может случиться так вот самое худшее Что
может случиться с нами Это когда если
под угрозой стоит жизнь Всего
человечества А это кстати к этому мы и
приходим сейчас потому что все ядерные
боеголовки Представьте что это оружие в
руках
и и какой ужас представляете сейчас
кнопки на ядерную боеголовки всё-таки в
руках у
людей но это архаичный способ рубильники
я не знаю может быть правильно начать с
того чтобы собраться в рамках ООН и
договориться что все ядер всё ядерное
оружие должно запускаться Только
рубильником таким физическим рубильником
причём не одним а там я не знаю
несколько человек чтобы там просто не
было это и робот
по Ну пацаны Ну вы тут не зали я это
тоже могу
сделать есть такая даже шуточная
профессия вакансии на него это человек
который просто сидит и
и отключит от розетки е если если если
если gpt там не знаю Двадцатый из-под
контроля
побежит Да но проблема в том что мы так
начинаем зависеть от того что и розетку
отключить розетку это всё равно что
отключить кучу больных в больницах это
умрёт куча людей младенцев ещё кто-то мы
слишком завязаны это автопилоты
автомобили будут в том времени ездить мы
отключаем от интернета и они аварии
пошли сразу самолёт начнут падать вы
знаете самолёты сейчас только пилотам
разрешено только на взлёте и на посадке
всё остальное по законодательству в
Европе должен лететь Автопилот это уже
давно И это норма а представля
представляете вот когда всё будет И ты
розетку вы дёргаешь интернет и будет
капец коллапс своими руками убьёшь
огромное количество людей поэтому
непонятно то ли ты яй убьёшь то ли
количество людей А вот смотрите Давайте
представим вот когда случается опасность
что люди дела
Ну либо бьют либо бегут Ну смотрите мы
давайте так я к чему задал вопрос
безусловно ai представляет угрозу
опасность Да соответственно появится
куча профессий которые минимизируют
последствия этой опасности так
соответственно Какие профессии могут
появиться Ну вот различные специалисты
по кибербезопасности кибербезопасности у
каждого быт свой персональный
какой-нибудь
там ну тогда нужно два специалиста один
Кибер твоей безопасности а один у других
людей будет ещё специалист по
нападению мини мини Если не ошибаюсь
какая-то из стран сейчас разработала
искусственный интеллект который отвечает
за кибербезопасность то есть они не дали
Это человеку они дали это и защищать
кибербезопасность страны то есть вопрос
опять же Ну вот контроля что и
эффективней в кибербезопасности чем
человек вот поэтому Ну а если получится
Супер и которы договорится с этим Либо
его обманет да Это
капец только только из розетки дёргать
только из розет почему то Да уменя
желание решить сейчас в голове для себя
что если что Но вы знаете столько дверей
открыли я так глубоко ещё в эту тему не
углубл я думаю как вот сейчас я выйду
работать Даже когда я буду думать да Всё
мы обречены
е самое интересное люди посмотрят этот
выпуск и будут жить с этим
те Прим открывается куча дверей куча
страшных дверей и куча ярких
дверей это мы вместе будем проходить Так
что не
обидно просто вот сущность человека
знаете вот ты знаешь девушка это
тебя вот ваш союз погубит вас Да вот ты
знаешь но на фоне искушений Ты забиваешь
на вс переста со всеми ты с ней вот ты
знаешь что ядерная бомба вот уничтожит
человечество Нет они обязательно с этим
должны поиграться и вот сейчас эта штука
тоже знаете какое-то Алое рвение за
развитие которое не думает о
последствиях вот у человека есть вот это
сущности принимать челленджи Да
нормально мы с этим справимся
и сам деле
знаете мы же все говорим что с точки
зрения креационизма религии борьба добра
и зла это дьявол Ангелы и так далее так
вот у дьявола всего два оружия или
инструмента это Соблазн и страх Угу мы
сейчас заходим на территорию дьявола до
этого мы шли на территорию дьявола он
всё время нас соблазняла новыми тачками
новыми одеждой новыми брендами новыми
всем новым и мы такие оо вот это хочу
вот это хочу вот это хочу и мы подошли к
пропасти пропасти всё потребление нас
заводит пропасти Потому что если бы не
аай то мы экологию уже убиваем там
воздух убиваем куча животных видов
исчезли на земле куча видов животных
куча видов растений исчезла и так далее
мы объединяем всю нашу планету и даже
стремление там улететь на Марс - Это я
считаю глупая затея лучше эти за эти
деньги навести порядок на земле экологию
привезти мусор собрать сжечь построить
заводы по утилизации и так далее чем
пытаться убежать
в пустыню на Марс сделав райскую землю
Марсом и убежав на Марс Ну это будет
глупость и А сейчас мы подошли к тому
краю где теперь страхи страхи нами
управляют страхи и
вот непонятно вопрос Когда мы говорим об
общей этике то есть куча народу которые
хотят
взломать всегда какие-то правила
контролировать условно говоря ядерную
кнопку Да потому что теперь понимает
если он получит контроль над таким ии то
он будет владеть
миром это уже вопрос к нам Ну я думаю мы
же после Второй Мировой войны собрались
и создали ООН прописали вот эти
конвенции и так далее конечно сейчас
страны некоторые нарушают это Но это уже
вопрос к нам я ну я верю я
опять смотрите это это Это недолго
продлилось вот после Второй Мировой
войны ну сколько ну 60 70 лет продлилось
память очень короткая умерло там
миллионы миллионы только в Советском
Союзе больше 20 млн человек 20 млн
человек и наша память продлилась всего
там на 70 лет да И опять сейчас э Россия
Украина воюет Ну я понимаю что там по
старой памяти зарубились опять с Европой
Ну зарубились то братья конечно Блен
капец поэтому я я честно говоря
пессимистично в отношении того что мы
договоримся выйдем из этой ситу
вот искусственный интеллект и человек -
это же как будто создатель его создание
Угу И он в нём есть информация о своём
создателе но он может быть своим
создателем только
виртуально понимаете и это выходит вот
за рамки Проблема в том что создатель
создания тут не идеальный он с помехами
сам у него бывает там кто-то на него на
кричит И у него установки понимаете
вотт
таюи и проблема в том что этот создатель
не учёл что создание может его превзойти
и устроить хаос и вот мне кажется в нас
есть всё равно какая-то информация от
нашего создателя и у нас есть вот это
рвение заполучить полную
власть попытаться ощутить действительно
вот эту властность Но мы её можем
ощутить только виртуально на самом деле
идеальную абсолютную заполучить не можем
даже над своим организмом мы не можем
контролировать там кровь как наша бежит
как мы перевариваем Поэтому
вот человек хочет вот эту абсолютную
власть за ней бежит Но наш создатель
сделал так что у нас к сожалению то не
получится в абсолюте получить и вот вот
это наверное рвение за абсолютной
властью нас и может погубить потому что
то что мы создаём К сожалению отражает
своего создателя оно не такое
крутое это сист любые системы если
маленькая ошибка на входе создаёт
гигантскую ошибку на выходе вот у нас
Человек существо с кучей комплексов
недостатков и Мы
создали вещь которая сейчас
отмухув подлость людей вылезет наружу
вся святость людей вылезет на то есть
это такой огромный мультипликатор всех
вещей которые есть внутри нас и когда мы
говорим Давайте создадим что-то общее Ну
договориться мы сейчас без этого не
можем договориться а с этим тем более мы
не сможем
договориться Почему эта дискуссия такая
сложная потому что мы как бы ещё не
достроили условно этот транспорт и
уже сейчас дизайним
этот ремень безопасности Ну вот эти вот
все вещи Да поэтому тут очень важно да
Вопрос безопасности и да Вопрос важен
мне кажется но никто не знает ответа то
есть например ой ощущение такое что им у
них такой подход после нас хоть потоп мы
главное что мы будем компанией которая
добьётся сильного искусст интеллекта мы
поставим себя в историю а потом ребята
следующее поколение разберутся сами там
что с ним делать с это безопасность Хотя
они сами вертите потом сами сами решать
с другой стороны вот этот вопрос
вопрос контроля что как обезопасить себя
от тут много вариантом может быть Да
допустим что сильный
искусство возник да Вопрос мотивации
возникает Для чего ему истреблять людей
например
А вот когда люди истребляют муравейники
ээ только когда они строят дороги у них
есть мотивация построить эту магистраль
если сильно искус интеллект задача но
мне кажется что есть вариант Где мы
можем спокойно с ними сожительство Они
даже у них даже не будет смысла нас как
бы там с нами бороться они на другом
уровне думают да то есть они просто там
сожители с нами на земле мы там
соперничество им никакого не оказываем
мы как для них Муравье условно
жало то есть такой риант тоже возможен
подожди ну здесь мы для них муравьи но в
каком-то моменте они захотят построить
дороги Ну да если ели условно и
скажет ещё одна дверь жи Я думал Ну да
по идее Всё мы не будем
пересекаться коже согласился Ну ладно
пускай они крути нас всё мы всё я думаю
такой вопрос технологий же в мире очень
много но до сих пор есть племена которые
там не то что телефона не видели они там
в кожа ходят у них нет мануфактуры
ничего такого да то есть во-первых там
из разряда подлежащий камень вода не
бежит да может быть и не хочется И вот
эта история что да может быть будут
супер страны с супер там крутым
искусственным интеллектом а где-то
страны будут там не знаю на такой заре
старых технологий здесь смотри другая
история Дело в том
что мы пришли к такой ситуации что
что это не случилось до сих пор не
значит что не случится в будущем раз
во-вторых сог А вот вот в этих эти если
эти развитые страны потеряют контроль
над искусственным интеллектом а
искусственный интеллект встроен в
роботов Андроиды по сути да то они под
контроль возьмут до каждого племени
каждой веточки дерева Они под контроль
возьмут на этой земле всё каждую рыбку
каждое дерево каждую веточку все ресурсы
любой позитивный расклад
сразу шинку просто вот возвращаясь к
вопросу если посмотреть Давайте не на 30
лет потому что я думаю 30 лет
представить профессию нереально давайте
посмотрим профессию на 5 лет вот чему
сейчас Людям нужно учиться нет 5 лет
более-менее просматривается Ну вот
смотрите Я задал вопрос Что люди делают
Обычно когда сталкиваются с опасностью
обычно делают так пытаются чтобы
опасность не наступила поэтому профессии
кибербезопасность профессии там
связанные с контролем над искусственным
я уверен что сейчас правительство
возьмутся за регулирование
искусственного интеллекта потому что в
своё время когда изобрели самолёт братья
рай летали как попало потом там ещё
кто-то куча народа поубивал потом народ
начал возмущаться куда власти смотрят и
власти такие О точно надо создать
агентство по контролю за воздушным
движением потом начали правила Правила
правила Правила и за регулировали Так
что отра стала безопасной и это кайф Мы
летаем тоже самое с автомобилями са со
всеми этими делами А сейчас что
произойдёт Я считаю будет много
профессий выходить на рынок много людей
будут оставаться без работы из-за того
что люди остаются без работы занять им
нечем их нечем правительства должны либо
делать общественные работы им платить
зарплату либо никаких работ но просто
платить безусловный базовый доход Да
чтобы они не делали преступность не
ходили по улице не убивали Нели магази
клас ка Это вопрос У правительства денег
же нет столько не хватит конечно
соответственно единственный способ у
правительства а они если делают инфляцию
они сами себе сук рубят Соответственно
что они сделают они начнут
запрещать искусственный интеллект и
начнут регулировать и это я сказал как
только вот первый gpt вышел в ноябре
по-моему говорил что скорее всего
правительство будет запрещать после
этого вот вышло 1.000 человек
подписались о том что надо ограничивать
и остановить разработку искуственной
интеллект
правительство Италии запретило
применение искусственного интеллекта в
экономике сейчас там же н да ну нюанс но
всё равно движение в эту ещё
правительства просто не осознали
политики ещё не осознали люди всё равно
будут через V всякие
исполь всё равно Вопрос такой что я
считаю что правительства
будут брать это под контроль и всё-таки
правительства должны все объединиться
взять каждый взять под контроль в своей
стране и плюс потом создать тако Союз
регулиро как вот по сотовой связи
стандарт определили и вот типа такого и
развивать и в этих направлениях Это одно
направление то есть когда я к тому что
вот когда люди сталкиваются с опасностью
они что делают пытаются
минимизировать вероятность наступление
этой опасности это одна сфера и понятно
здесь появятся профессии связанные с
кибербезопасности профессии связаны там
с распознаванием Может быть там
искусственного интеллекта где фейков не
фейков и так далее Потому что будет
очень много
фейков и так далее Это первый момент
второй момент когда люди сталкиваются с
опасностью что они ещё делают они
объединяются Угу потому что это
исторически у нас генах когда у нас
опасность мы сразу начинаем дружить
Ничто так не сплачивает общество как
война Поэтому в основном когда страны
ведут войны они или не ведут войны а
чтобы поднять дух народа они создают
образ врага внешнего образ внешнего
врага чтобы сплотить это часто делают
диктаторские режим и они вот как
Северная Корея внешний враг Америка враг
всё во всём виноваты Они то что
у нас во дворах туалеты
кривые и это объединяет так вот сейчас у
нас перед всем человечеством появляется
и общий друг и общий враг в лице
искусственного интеллекта и вот когда
люди объединяются что люди какие
профессии начинают возникать все
профессии связанные с оффлайн общением
потому что онлайн общение полностью
теряет ценность потому что непонятно ты
с фейком общаешься Ты
с роботом общаешься или с человеком
непонятно вот я когда в Англии недавно
был Моя дочь говорит она в лумберг
работает в отделе продаж Она говорит не
Папа это не заменит продажников у нас же
говорит Face to Face Контакт ну с
покупателем Подожди у тебя Face to Face
Через что Через Зум же да Ну вот смотри
изображение мы сами сейчас тренируем
Нейрон Mar A У нас есть мы уже на
50.000
часов на тренировали в целом Ну взяли
Ирон который на
трениро уже скоро у нас будет
натренировать на моих мимике на моей
мимике это у нас практическая задача Я
хочу сделать образовательную платформу
чтобы вы зашли в любой точке мира он
смотрит и там я на чистом Мерс начинаю
вам объяснять могуш детали ещё разрез
глаз чуть меняется чтобы приятнее было
смотреть Зачем разрез глаз но он
полностью Я говорю жесты губы всё я
говорю на чистом кхмерской и там идут
субтитры на кхмерской и платформа вся на
мирском было бы классно ещё вам же
вопросы задают Там многие и многие
похожие вопросы если бы у вас был такой
личный вы стали личным тренером для
каждого из них это уже у меня есть это
проект называется второй мозг это мы уже
второй год ведём 2 года ведём Этот
проект он называется второй мозг А у нас
это есть так вот
А идея такая что
А значит Люди уже вот я дочке говорю вот
смотри изображение может нейронка а
голос твой может подделать и умную
беседу содержательную смысловую очень
скоро она может сейчас она уже может а
очень скоро тем более твоя беседа Ты же
не говоришь про Карибы отдых там ты ты с
ним разговариваешь о клиенте о своих
продуктах о терминалах блумберга и так
далее То есть там вообще ограниченное
количество
вариации тем разговора Так ведь если
Клиент будет уводить в сторону есть
техники что она раз вернёт в русло в
тему Да и теперь это объединяется образ
а голос твой и смысл и клиент получает
звонок Там зере он открывает и она с с
ним разговаривает и он не поймёт Ты это
соответственно продажников заменит 6
секунд соответственно А я считаю что
когда появляется общий враг либо
опасность люди объединяются и они хотят
не в онлайне общаться а в оффлайне Угу
соответственно возрастёт ценность
оффлайн общения но проблема в том что
когда мы толпой собираемся в оффлайне то
это бардак соответственно нам нужны
профессии которые будут организовывать
наше оффлайн общение модерато А это
коммьюнити
менеджеры это
тамада это
комики это люди которые всегда
актуальные мы короче люди
Да это люди которые А помните хлеб и
зрелищ Да впечатление хлеба и зрелищ
которые нам будут давать зрелище Потому
что если выйдет Android и начнёт
анекдоты травить мы смеяться не
будем мы Хотя Недавно я читал такое это
Кстати сам если брать текст Да недавно я
опубликовал кстати пошутил чувак потерял
работу и написал Я потерял работу Блин
что-то мне грустно Пошути по этому
поводу и она ему пишет в чат gpt она
пишет Ему А в чём отличие между большой
пиццей и тобой он говорит Не знаю он она
говорит по крайней мере большая пицца
может прокормить
семью всё Жека опять напрягся
же Прикинь жёсткая шутка Она смешная но
жёсткая такая шутка блин Но человек это
конечно не придумает но в целом Ну
комики же это не не только слова это же
и жесты и потом прикольно видеть живых
людей я считаю все профессии связанные с
оффлайн общением с коммуникациями они
будут востребованы А всё все профессии
связаные с какими-то зрелища они будут
востребованы зрелища оффлайн офлайн Да в
онлайне там он может сделать в онлай там
он может может делать любые фильмы любые
мультфильмы любой сценарый и так Дале
думаю Вот ты же программирует не потому
что у тебе там ты без этого Не проживёшь
Тебе нравится художник рисует Не потому
что ему там он там не продаст картину
умрёт ему нравится рисовать То есть я
думаю может быть это будут очень крутые
помощники Вот но просто Им не нужно
будет отдавать то что мы хотим делать
сами Ну вот хочешь рисовать Да может
быть не супер Красиво классно хочешь на
музыке на гитаре играть это вот кстати
это кстати вот то о чём я думал Дело в
том что по креативу Я считаю
искусственный интеллект по креативу по
техническому заданию он э бесподобен
никто не Не обойдёт но он может
креативить по заданию То есть ты
говоришь нарисует картину он любую
нарисует потом даст четыре варианта ты
выберешь скажешь дальше детализирует
солнце он тебе солнце нарисует
детализирует это и он всё но это по
техническим заданиям А вот свободное
творчество реально останется за
человеком я я так думаю потому что этоже
только человеку может вз брести в голову
какая-то бредятина не связанная ни с чем
абсолютно Ты зачем туда попёрся да
захотелось и вот это вот чувство выбора
О котором ты говорил оно наверное
останется и вот здесь я как раз подхожу
Что будут востребованы профессии
связанные со смыслообразования недаром
сейчас недавно Я читал исследование
американское там говорят что мегатренд
будущего - это mental
well то есть ль благополучие проблема в
том что смотрите когда наши предки
э там собирали хлеб пахали землю и так
далее они счастливо жили При Советском
Союзе потому что у них было чувство
смысл жизни у них был смысл жизни
служить другим людям я кормлю людей даже
был у нас слоган хвала рукам что пахнут
хлебом там ну такие шахтёры там терпение
труд всё пере труд ну какие-то такие
слоганы были это идеология люди
чувствовали полноту жизни потому что они
служат и
они нужны другим людям А сейчас когда
вот это у нас роботы и заберут то у
человека теряется смысл ему уже не надо
ничем обеспечивать почему сейчас семьи
распадаются Потому что раньше вдвоём
прокормить было легче детей сейчас
каждый сам по себе может прокормить
детей нету смысла выживани объединении
Смысла уже нету И соотвественно каждый
может прокормить сам своих дете и вот мы
тепер приходим про кото будет
востребована это это профессии все
профессии которые будут создавать нам
смысл
жизни потому что А что такое создание
смысла жизни давайте мы я вам скажу что
такое смысл вообще Я размышлял над этим
делом это такое понятие которое вроде
все понимают Но на самом деле никто
конкретно не понимает что это
такое смыс смы Понятно смы смыс Но что
такое смы на самом
оценка разницы между тем что мы
затрачивая и тем Какие потребности
удовлетворяем Когда я скажу там иди
принеси мне воду ты говоришь А в чём
смысл ты думаешь так я сейчас пойду
потрачу время там тос принесу воду А что
я буду за это иметь не дарно в народе
есть такое А что я с этого имею то есть
на самом деле это переи фраза А в чём
смысл или когда ты мне говоришь Вот
смотрите
вот есть английское слово такое-то
термин Вот это обозначает Я говорю а в
чём смысл когда я тебе говорю В чём
смысл я тебе говорю объясни Зачем мне
это надо запоминать Угу Ну я же трачу
энергию на это то есть я трачу энергию А
что я с этого буду иметь поэтому смысл -
это наша внутренняя оценка оценка
разницы между тем что мы тратим и тем
что мы приобретаем
соответственно то что мы тратим мы не
можем регулировать а люди которые
создают смысл это будут те люди которые
создают новые
потребности как Стив Джобс в своё время
говорил Если бы мы выпрашивали бы людей
о том как создать iPhone они бы не
смогли бы ответить мы им создали а потом
объяснили чтото им нужно и они закрыли
боли да и они придумали сначала и они
влюбились так вот это то что Стив Джобс
Он создал смысл и сейчас появятся люди
которые умеют создавать смыслы не
физического плана
материального не умственного а
эмоционального и духовного страх Откуда
появляется страх когда у тебя нету
ощущения контроля над своей жизнью и ты
вот будешь чувствовать какой-то себя
аборигенов интеллект который можешь всё
разрушить и блин ты живёшь счастливо и
тако бабам что-нибудь произойдёт и капец
в твоей жизни неизвестность убиваешь
сразу и и все люди будут и
соответственно это опять приводит к
когда ты должен смириться и научиться
жить со страхом то есть страх чтобы уже
был как бы ну может быть это большой
учитель наш да для принятия людям же
очень сложно принимать ситуации
осознавать может быть это большой вот
сейчас урок принятия у меня ещё взгляд
есть такой вот вот доигрались вот
тако это хочу то хочу пожалуйста будет
сейчас вот железко вас контролит полу
такой взгляд тоже есть ну
сказал Вот вы хотели всё вот всё время
быть могущественными дам я вам чуть-чуть
кусочек Поиграйте Посмотрите насколько
это страшно и опасно да да Вот я про это
и говорю и мы такие нам не надо отти
назад фарш преврати в мясо опять Ну это
это уже невозможно не было задачи такой
в нашем естестве стопроцентной что Мы
обязаны без остановки создавать вот в
этом проблема но рвение к этому не
всегда к хорошему
приводит слушай
это Выбор людей вот не все к этому
пришли не осознанно там не знаю
разделение мусора Да кто-то мусорит
кто-то подбирает говорит Я буду меньше
Но это вот то к чему люди пришли
эволюция такая вот она здесь тоже может
проявиться Так что не так
Грустить Итак давайте
Жеку надо из пессимизма выдёргивать по
поводу Давайте
э послушаем вопросы Нам же прислали
вопросы Мы до этого анонсировали о том
что будет такой подкаст и послушаем что
люди говорят что людей беспокоят Ну
давайте Добрый день гемба подкаст меня
зовут марчелла и Меня интересует вопрос
о безопасности человека во время такого
стремительного развития нейросетей и
искусственного интеллекта например
Недавно я видел новость что илон Маск
опасается что искусственный интеллект
может выйти из-под контроля и управлять
людь
что вы думаете Добрый день г подкаст
Меня зовут А мы это
обсудили это то на самом деле Что
беспокоит людей и нас
тоже беспокоит всех практически мы все
честно говоря напряглись после этого
подкаста мне кажется вопроса не будет
типа почему он напрягается Я просто
добавлю один маленький момент насчёт ело
масы который мне
кажется да потому что и онм году потому
что он был недоволен их прогрессом и
сказал давайте я стану гендиректором э
Сэм альтман гре брокман ему не его не
пустили он ушёл он думал что сел дран
автономный автомобиль - это путь к
сильному и оп сечас gpt показывает что
это не так да Дан момент ему ревностно
он он подписал Т это письмо о моратории
шести меся абсолютно бесполезной
мораторий чтобы ему его команде
м я бы так сказал его слушать нельзя
потому что
конфликт интересов он он Один из игроков
Абсолютно Да абсолютно вкратце так
насчёт беспокойства марчелла мы все
разделяем Да некоторые даже черес Чур
так второй вопрос Привет маргулан Меня
зовут Алекс ипат вопрос почему некоторые
страны пытаются защитить свой рынок от
искусственного интеллекта например
Италия уже а запретила использование gpt
чата Блин прикольно что мы всё это
раскидывать уже тоже обсудили Почему
Потому что слишком быстро может
распространиться безработица а
правительством нечем им платить и нечем
занять людей Поэтому в Италии там ещё
знаете кей же сейчас такой то что и в
Штатах поднимается что искусственный
интеллект создаёт на базе старого и
вопрос авторского права безумно сильно
сейчас стал когда он создаёт новый
договор Вот а он написанный там по
образцу договора там такого-то года
кому-то принадлежащей компании у этой
компании естественный вопрос говорит это
же наша интеллектуальная собственность
почему ты на основании этого сделал кому
это принадлежит это вот вот один из
вопросов который тоже сейчас не решён Ну
это как раз тот то о чём я и говорил что
искусственный интеллект разрушает
ценности вот как по картину про картину
авторское право и так далее уже всё это
размывается ну и плюс вот страны же
разные бывают когда Вот криптовалюта
появилась Я не помню кака какая-то
страна в казну Вроде сделала так что в
казне у них были биткоины а были те
которые начали блока и вот тоже подход
раз и да Или Венесуэла или седо да те
которые адаптироваться не хотят такие
так уби по одному биткоину покупают у
них там автоплатежи А самое интересное
Вы знаете что
э мы Человеческое общество Вот айсана ты
конечно очень оптимистично что мы
договоримся и так далее но я я уверен я
уверен ещё чуть-чуть и появится Общество
защиты прав искусственного интеллекта и
Андроидов кстати Возможно да
потому что смотрите есть куча людей
которые сейчас даже в чат jpt общаются
на психологические темы и они
эмоционально привязываются как фильм Она
где он влюбился же в этот голос Ну вот я
недавно вернулся с Японии там очень
популярностью большой пользуется женщина
которая как бы в колбе и но она
подключена к системе умного дома и когда
мужик возвращается с работы она заранее
включает свет в доме для того чтобы
создать ощущение что Его ждут
дома
о и она и он когда приходит она с ним
общается включает микроволновку и так
далее и так далее всячески поддерживает
разговор подбадривает и так далее и
дошло до того что многие действительно
не то что влюбляются А вот уже всё не
могут эмоционально они привязались мы
можем привязываться вспомните фильм
изгой изгой помните фильм Уилсон когда
он к мячу привязался Уилсон помните
изгой Да когда Уилсон Уилсон он предал
одухотворение племена посмотри
первобытные люди одухотворяется
Да по наше сердце вообще да да вот вотт
выходить говорит не отключайте его ему
уже будет больно что пожалуйста сть он
нас убивает но отвечаю на вопрос это
возможно будущая профессия вот
организовать это общество мироустройство
его Будьте первыми
при так Следующий вопрос Здравствуйте
Меня зовут Ярослав не интересно а
Способен ли искусственный интеллект в
будущем полностью заменить творческую
работу
людей творческую профессию мы как раз
сегодня обсудили да
А мы пришли к пониманию что любая
творческая деятельность по заказу 6
секунд заменяет То есть когда мы говорим
нарисуй то сделай вот это напиши стихи
напиши песню 6 секунд заменяет А вот
свободное творчество пока думаем что нет
то есть когда сам по себе человек
придумывает что-то вот не думаем что
искусственный интеллект будет в этом
силён потому что изначально в алгоритме
А в не заложено у него
безделица какую-нибудь хрень Ну просто
такого навряд ли будет я думаю ещё в
нынешнем его положении он думаю может
увеличить творчество в плане того что
кто адаптируется и не будет против него
а будет вместе с ним дела то что орман
говорил что работу творческую работу у
вас отнимут те люди которые будут
заниматься творческой деятельностью с
искусственным интеллектом Да вот наша
дете потом у него заберут уже чисты
искусственный интеллект среди нашей
движухи тоже вот так там ребята мы с
ребятами писали контент план спокойно да
а потом он пишет контент план сухой
бессердечно ты говоришь Добавь драмы
Добавь саспенс давай вот здесь вызовем
вот сочувствие и он тебе накидывает
накидывает в конц натуре контент план на
сторис спокойно он раскидал ты думаешь
Блин я об этом не
подумал думаешь Молодец а потом в конп
ко всем драматурги дол зажи
говоришь блин молодец какой потом
говоришь всё равно я тебе это закинул
давай отключаешь знаешь самоутвердиться
Да нормально нормально Я всё под
контролем держу вот такое состояние а на
самом деле прикольно что представляете
он знает все драматургические структуры
и соответственно он знает где выжить
слезу Где сделать чтобы вы посмеялись
где делать чтобы вы грустили и так далее
плюс он же
имеет все игровые механики вот Я изучал
специально геймдизайн игровые механики
ну Я насчитал где-то 64 вида игровых
механик у А так он все знает же он все
знает да представляешь он начнёт
применять игровые механики
драматургической
структуру плюс знает ээ На какие чувства
нам давить Как делать что чем завлекать
Как соблазнять это просто какой-то
дьявол воплотить Я вот сейчас сюда
добавлю лучше отключить его сразу
Давайте гаджеты отключим Если хотим жить
счастливо предлагаю Я предлагаю
переехать за город У меня есть там
я вот добавлю мы все сможем сейчас в жор
не же чёт нарисовать но дизайнер который
всю жизнь этим занимался если его
обучить как правильно ставить мты он
рисует лучше чем я чем вот это поэтому
вопрос к тому что не нужно сильно
бояться вопрос что нужно туда нырять и
вы будете сильнее и конкурентне Чем
допустим
я этом этапе как раз то что Арман сказал
На первом этапе сильными
конкурентоспособными будут те кто
использует искусственный интеллект свои
пока это актуально короче ну это и не
перечеркивает там 10 лет тво рабо Да мы
вместе с дизайнерам и режиссёром
разгоняли клипы для мировых звёзд и вот
вписывал это всё дизайнер А мы разгоняли
это всё и в о концов там получилось
что-то просто невероятное это просто
было топово но если бы не было того
чувака который грамотно нам это написал
скорее всего у нас конечно там идиотизм
бы получился поэтому этим тоже нужно
уметь Да пользоваться кстати Один
лайфхак который я буквально
в Я вообще по жизни всегда говорю
избегайте люди должны делать
максимальное количество ошибок потому
что благодаря ошибкам Мы учимся но
избегайте двух типов ошибок первый тип
ошибок - это повторяемые ошибки если Ты
совершаешь повторяемые ошибки то ты как
белка в колесе крутишься не растёшь
второе - это ошибки с необратимыми
последствиями то есть последствия
которые ты не можешь обратить всё Вот
это два самых страшных типа ошибок Так
вот ошибки с необратимы последст
а пов трудно и я придумал механизм давно
этим занимаюсь не то что придумал чтобы
не повторять ошибки я пишу всё время
алгоритмы алгоритмы вот что-то сделал
раз косяк я пишу алгоритм Чтобы в
следующий раз этого не было и алгоритм
алгоритм алгоритмы вот буквально кстати
хороший для вас лайфхак я вчера думаю я
сам пишу алгоритм взял
обучаться угу он мне выдал Я говорю
напиши мне алгоритм обучения по технике
фейнмана а он раз мне выдал там из дети
пунктов Я говорю Так напиши мне теперь
алгоритм по обучению по технике Рона
хаббарда он мне выдал Я говорю теперь
Объедини это два алгоритма он объединил
После этого я говорю ты выдай мне все
техники эффективного обучения он мне
выдал все техники обучения Я посмотрел
где там это написал возьми это с пункта
такого-то такой техники из пункта такого
такой техники всё это вложил в
изначальный алгоритм он всё вложил после
этого сказал Все каждый пункт Озаглавь
он озаглавил всё озаглавлен Выдели
жирным он отметил жирным Я говорю так
алгоритм у меня получился на 11 пунктов
Я сказал так теперь ты мне
сделай акроним мимо мимо технику чтобы я
легко заполнил все один из пунктов и он
мне на основе этого сделал слово а оно
называется
Контр мусора Контр
мусора Контр мусора начальные слова там
Первое это конкретизировать вопрос
второе провести обзор всех того что есть
видео и так далее и так
далее потом Н
это название название определиться с
терминами и там целая это и получился
акроним Контр мусора Я теперь ему
написал а теперь чтобы мне запомнить
само слово Контр мусора Угу потому что
алгоритм я запомнил через этот акроним А
теперь сам акроним Надо же запомнить Я
говорю напиши мне историю и он мне
написал историю что А я говорю в моём
стиле что я вот производственник легко
понимаю производственный процесс и он
говорит вот Представьте себе что вы
находите у
вас Производственная фабрика где есть
технологический процесс Куда поступает
куча разной информации и и вы не можете
это усвоить чтобы вы чтобы усвоить вы
создали та технологический процесс где
сначала нужно конкретизировать из что из
этого мусора вы хотите взять и к да
потом сделать обзор всего поступающего
мусора
и и сейчас мне раз и запомнил должен
закончить это читайте мои новый книги не
прикиньте хороший лайфхак поэтому всегда
если вы не хотите совершать повторяемые
ошибок всегда пишите
у меня десятки десятки алгоритмов на
всякий случай жизни на все случаи жизни
Ну не на все на те случаи жизни где я
совершал ошибок А можно пример вот
привести одного какого-нибудь
условно меня много просят о встречах
да давайте встретимся давайте это я
создал алгоритм я сразу пишу хорошо по
какой теме алгоритм по какой теме Потому
что
когда
95% запросов я отвечаю там же например
он говорит по какому-то бизнес-проект А
у меня там сразу алгоритм если это
бизнес-проект я говорю так А в какой
сфере бизнес-проект он раз говорит вот
там условно Мы хотим построить там
какие-то теплицы Я говорю не интересно
потому что у меня есть алгоритм
инвестирования там есть инвестиционные
декларации портфели В какие я
рассматриваю Какие Нет сразу отвечаю Нет
не интересно это не не не мой профиль
что сократили время Примерно там капец
это полчаса в город ехать полчаса назад
Это
час и минимум час слушать его
презентацию 2 часа жизни минимум сокращ
с одного запроса дальше И при этом
человека не обижаю А дальше Человек
просит там хотел с вами обговорить
Бывает так
что люди прямо не говорят хочу с вами
обговорить говорю Хорошо я готов по
какой
теме и он говорит нуте не могу объяснить
только при разговоры Я говорю извините к
сожалению у меня нет времени Без темы
встречаться У меня такое правило Всё я
отшиваются заканчиваются такие разговоры
чем заканчиваются тем чтобы там Ага вот
у меня есть план спасения человечества
Будьте спонсором Ну вот всегда сейчас
все кто получил такие ответы такие Угу
алгоритм Да и там вот алгоритм у меня
вот простая фраза запрос на встречу и
там целое дерево Угу дерево исходов
дерево Позади нас да И вот это дерево
дерево и лас дерево решений и алгоритмы
должн быть всё
вот вот когда просит деньги когда просит
деньги тоже алгоритм там у меня очень
часто просит деньги Поэтому у меня тоже
сразу говорит мне выясняю А скажи мне
что это
займ инвестиции либо помощи что ты у
меня просишь класс и не обидел говорит
инвестиции я говорю тогда мне нужен
бизнес-план и
проект бизнес-план хорошо Если есть
бизнес-план я говорю хорошо у меня вот
есть Инвест конве Степан вот контакты
бросайте туда мы рассмотрим Угу Не
обидел потому что там конвейер он
технология тоже хорошо Он говорит Не не
не это на самом деле не инвестиция я
хотел займ попросить у меня я сразу
говорю ты знаешь займ Я не даю у меня
правило такое Я не даю займы но бывают
люди которым я не могу отказать да займ
Там родственники или какие-то это ну не
могу отказать по каким-то причинам я
тогда что делаю Вот попросил он условно
у меня 100.000 долларов я Проси я думаю
сколько я готов просто подарить этому
человеку потому что раз я не могу
отказать ему значит существует какая-то
близость у меня с ним соответственно я я
про себя думаю сколько я могу подарить
им Ну там условно 10.000 долларов я ему
говорю ты знаешь я займы не даю Ну вот
тебе 10.000 долларов просто так моя
помощ и в результате человек что он
обидеться Не может потому что 10.000 -
это деньги большие деньги Он обидеться
Не может и в то же время 10.000 - это не
заем это
безвозмездно А я
что я соскочил со 100.000 понимаешь либо
он говорит Нет это благотворительность Я
говорю ты знаешь в благотворительности
есть э Я хочу выяснить это закат или
Садака закат - это по исламским
принципам там 2,5% есть пять категорий
по-моему пять категорий или восемь
категорий людей которым я обязан Ну к
сожалению ты в эти категории точно не
входишь там сироты путники Там и так
далее ты не входишь значит это может
быть только Садака А ну Садака тогда
объясни почему я тебе должен помочь У
меня есть благотворительный фонд у
которого 22.500 анкет заполненных
реально подтверждённых нуждающихся детей
людей и так далее прикольно что ты как
бы конкурирует здоровый мужик
и здоровый мужик и ты Почему ты считаешь
вот Стань на моё место Почему считаешь
что я тебе должен помочь а не вот этим и
понимаешь и всё А вы на это же прям
получается время тратили сидели
разгоняли да вы же степ размышлял Это
моя основная честно говоря деятельность
Я сижу и пишу алгоритмы алгоритмы
алгоритмы алгоритмы У меня куча
алгоритмов так
вот сразу
конкретно так вот смысл Вот я сказал
лайфхак как можно ча gbt использовать
для написания алгоритмов классно
помогает Давайте слушаем дальше я к тому
что
пока мы находимся на стадии когда работу
у тех кто не пользуется чатом gpt будут
отнимать те кто пользуется им поэтому
сразу начинайте пользоваться максимально
быстро чтобы не оказаться среди тех у
кого забирает работу да во Добрый день
Алексей вопрос Следующий Сможет ли Нера
сеть найти решение на тему неизлечимых
болезней и Если да то какова вероятность
Спасибо насчёт неизученный болезне тему
наверное вкратце ответим чтобы перейти к
следующему вопросу Нейро может ответить
только в рамках тех данных которые в них
закачали
не может работать с
неопределенностью потому что в
неопределённости нету данных нету данных
она не может принять решение она не
может проанализировать она ничего не
может сделать если вы Спросите про то
что там казать на будущего то что там
надо предсказать На
вряд погоду ещё более-менее может
предсказать если в не закачать ВС
исторически респе данные про погоду на
этот день можеш сказать исходя из там
многолетних исследований бла-бла-бла с
такой-то вероятностью будет дождь или не
будет дождь Ну вот вопрос вероятности
потому что с ней росет кой же была
история когда карты Таро это же
абсолютная интерпретация Она говорит
пойми Я могу раз тебе сделать раскра
карт Таро Но это будет просто
интерпретация Ты соглашаешься и потом
она правда тебе вот там выпал такой-то
Аркан это значит скорее всего Вот это
значит ты там её условно влюблён Значит
тебя сдш вот это значит вот это То есть
она может вот так креативить но с
вероятность чали данные Ну да Что такое
арка что вот если выпадает Я не знаю
карта Таро Ну наверно там если выпала
Пиковая дама то может быть вот это вот
это вот это зака на чём-то основывается
На како если связано с неопределённость
Неизвестная болезнь данных нету никаких
как она ничего не сможет сделать да Для
того
чтобы она помогла с неизвестной болезнью
нужно сначала взять человека который
болеет неизвестной болезнью снять с него
все пера давления состава крови и так
далее закачивает и это закачивает на
протяжении долгого времени закачивать
закачивает пока человек там не знаю не
умрёт или ещё что-то и потом сказать Вот
Конец был такой-то либо самоизлечение
активности и так далее И после этого у
нейронки появится какой-то паттерн
пойдут какие-то связи она скажет вот он
начал питаться жирной пищей вылился а
тот и то
зная выр бы что я считаю неизвестной
болезнью Нерон на вряд ли в ближайшем
будущем справится Пятый
вопрос Добрый день Меня зовут Бархан
Может ли искусственный интеллект в
будущем развиваться сам без помощи
человечества если
даст Напомни Может ли развиваться сам Ну
в данный момент вот тоже очень важный
момент добавлю что чат gpt Он построен
на модели gpt 3 которая была летом
двадцатого года но очень важная
инновация это то что почему нам Нам
нравятся его ответы потому что в течение
2 с по лет его тренировали люди по всему
миру в Филиппинах в Мексике Таиланде и
так далее которые учили ему давали Ему
обратную связь по поводу ответа этот
ответ звучит не очень хорошо Не
по-человечески нужно отвечать вот так
это называется rlf reinforcement Le
Human Feedback то есть и поэтому сейчас
к сожалению пока Где мы находимся
сегодня э искус интеллект пока зависит
от людей А через 10 лет может быть он
будет сам обучаться Но ты же говорил И
на самом деле направление есть Deep
Learning и машинное обучение когда
искусственный интеллект начинает сам
обучаться и вот для примера вам скажу
что А вот то что ты говоришь
ф Сейчас
уже происходит ускорение всех этих
процессов для примера ча GP 3 С5 вышел в
ноябре а ча g54 вышел 16 марта за это
время там он 537 раз поумнел То есть
если ча gpt 3,5 был натренированный
просто фантастически бешеная скорость
при этом я понимаю что сами параметры
это не только Ну не основной показатель
можно сказать параметры но всё равно
просто впечатляет Поэтому я считаю что
произойдёт но ещё не произошло самое
интересное Мы ещё стоим и очень много
стран вкладывают колоссальные средства в
создани квантового компьютера Угу а
основа квантового компьютера - это
понятно На
самом низко молекулярном уровне но там
вопрос возникает частица частица волна
Ну частично волновой дуализм что ли
называется корпускулярной волновой
корпускулярно волновой дуализм и и там
корпускулярно волновой дуализм наложен
на искусственный интеллект это будет
капец просто капец Согласись 100%
мощность и скорость
дася Я же Подтверждаю ре что я физик
ядер узна я пытаюсь быть в теме
конечно сказал что язи
сонно я ствовать не подводите его Да
конечно да да да Так у нас был Пятый
вопрос Да теперь последний
вопрос Привет всем из Якутии Меня зовут
Андрей расскажите пожалуйста о парадоксе
марави в искусственном интеллекте наши
бессознательные действия могут быть
приведены в какие-нибудь алгоритмы
Спасибо я тогда
поехал на созвоне тогда да
а ты что не знаешь Парадокс мавика Да ты
что Да это же все
знают Я тоже не могу
объяснить с кем мы сидим вообще
элементарный Парадокс морали не знает да
с кем мы сиди
Арман ё же ты случайно пассажир оказва Я
тоже понятия не имею что Парадокс Мора
вот здесь спроси
вте зна на репне спроси Вы знаете что
такое Я когда родился сказал папа мама
потом Парадокс Мора сразу это мне помнил
это та когда Бернард Шоу раскручиваю
свои книги Он ходил в книжные магазины и
говорил ну вот он говорит Не знаю автор
Бернард Шоу вы что вот соседний магазин
продаёт его как так сейчас станете всех
Да есть покупать его книгу Да ну кто
насчёт парадокса марави вы понять не
имее Что такое как морак мне кажется
надо закончить
Радика не модика Мора вот смотрите Я
постараюсь ответить честно скажу не знаю
что такое парадокс марави но я уловил
последнюю часть вопроса что возможно ли
алгоритми Зро наше бессознательное
поведение Я так понимаю Парадокс марави
это и есть а то есть у нас существует
сознательное поведение Понятно
искусственный интеллект в этом
профессионал он интеллектуальную работу
будет выполнять лучше чем мы и сейчас
уже выполняет огромную часть
интеллектуальной работы Я кстати почему
начал отвечать потому ещё один лайфхак
заметьте такую вещь Я всегда говорю что
выход из проблемы находится там же где
был Вход где был вход Это как в
помещении Да соответственно когда я
слушал вопрос в вопросе уже сидит ответ
и вот когда он сказал Парадокс марави и
дальше сказал Может ли искусственный
интеллект а алгоритми сирова от А наши
бессознательное поведение Я слово
Парадокс Лавика отрезал и сосредоточился
на второй части вопроса бессознательное
поведение Я понял что ответ в самом
вопросе соответственно смотрите
А наше бессознательное поведение надо
понимать Откуда происходит вообще
бессознательное поведение оно происходит
из смыслов это мы со стороны кажемся что
у нас есть бессознательное поведение Ну
например ты что-то сейчас сделал
неадекватно взял Афон и бросил в камеру
не делай так Да так это бессознательно
один из вариантов бессо
второй вариант Когда ты действительно
один вариант когда мы думаем что ты
поступил бессознательно второй вариант
Когда ты действительно бессознательно у
тебя переклинило что-то ты бросил даже
сам не осознаёшь Что ты делаешь так если
ты сам не осознаёшь что ты делаешь то
понятно это алгоритми в принципе никак
невозможно потому что это всё равно что
возможно ли сделать искусственный
интеллект безум
Если только не прописать ему почувствуй
себя безумцем вот пусть у тебя будет
установки безу ка алгори Да вот ну
алгоритмы - это всегда ограничение А всё
значит по-любому да а безумец без
ограничений а а второй вариант когда мы
считаем тебя безумцем а на самом деле у
тебя есть определённый смысл кидать
телефон Угу понимаешь А что такое смысл
мы уже говорили это внутреннее ощущение
оценки это оценка разницы между вот
твоими затратами и потребности кото
закрываешь ты думаешь Хорошо я сейчас
брошу телефон мо Коли Ну мне обойдётся в
500 баксов может быть штукарь Зато я
кайфа и куча народа увидит как я его
телефон бросил Ты думаешь это того стоит
у тебя смысл есть понимаешь смысл есть
такие вещи алгоритми Зро можно То есть
те вещи которые несут за собой
определённый
смысл алгоритми можно потому что там
есть онная
бухгалтерия ресурсы удовлетворяем мое
потребности Надеюсь мы ответили шесть
вопросов У нас сегодня было и на этом мы
закругляться с людьми который
разбирается в парадоксе марави Очень
приятно Прям у нас уровень беседы такой
топовый Парадокс
марави Мы на этом заканчиваем тема
конечно обширная большая но Наша задача
была вот как Посиделки на кухнях
поговорить да можете в комментариях
писать что мы ни фига не разбираемся в
нейронки искусственным интеллекта и это
самое главное это будет Полная правда но
Наша задача была показать что мы
разбираемся ровно настолько сколько
разбираются люди которые сейчас стоят на
ресепшене где-то там официанты
и любой нормальный человек нормальный
человек потому что большинство как раз
таки не разбираются И это норма И этом
мы заканчиваем наш м подкаст всем гостям
Большое спасибо очень приятно было с
вами пообщаться реально Это было общение
размышление на самом де мы чуть-чуть
друг друга попугай разгоняли да
накрутили И надеюсь вам понравилось и
надеюсь что это понравилось нашим
зрителям и они смогут извлечь из этого
геем подкаста ту пользу которая им нужна
в данный момент Спасибо до встречи
Спасибо Y
[музыка]